Boom, and we're live. Yeah.
The first guy with a high top ever to wear these mind.
I was wondering whether or not the microphones were gonna sit with perfect.
Yeah. This is right in this little crevice fluffy like a little rest area.
Does that help? This haven't that much here on the top of your head.
Is there any benefit of that?
I think when you get like elbowed or anything like that,
I think it helps out a ton. Like if someone,
if you have someone in their guard and they're trying to elbow the top of your
head, I would imagine. Yeah, it's a little cushion on it.
So I think it protects you and I kind of grew up the bed for that.
Kind of that same reason. But it doesn't get as burly as I kind of wanted to.
But it works. I think in boxing they used to make people shave their beard.
Yeah. That's probably why impact I, you know that kid desi green,
I used to live with him, he's in the UFC also. And, um,
whenever I put that guy in the g cause he has these big dreads and he would
always get out of them because the dreads were like it gave his head and made
his head appear like it was bigger.
So you wrap around it and you squeezed the cushion and it just compresses and
then he just, his head just slides out of it completely. Ah,
so it's like a cheat code. Slippery, slippery dreadlocks.
I would also imagine though that having a bald head if you get sweaty would make
it a little grease here. Like if you have stubble like on the top of your head,
that would provide like a little bit of friction. Yeah, it makes sense.
I follow you. I follow you on that. I haven't had a bullet head though,
so I don't, I I start for me to know.
I like how your shirt even has a gold chain on it.
I was going to wear the big boy chain today but as done, I dunno. I Dunno.
You only carry that out when you fight. I usually do.
I try to keep it not like too ridiculous all the time, you know?
Try to be like only in character, like make it for like,
like a special occasion type of thing. There's even,
I would consider this a special occasion,
but I try to make it more of a like a MMA thing. Oh,
there's something extra special about a tee shirt with gold chain on it at all.
It might be more special than an actual gold chain itself. Hey works.
So it's kind of silly. You got man up. How much does that thing weigh?
The real one. I'm not very heavy.
[inaudible] it's like 10 pounds now.
I wish it was 10 pounds every 10 pounds of gold. But uh,
it's not as nice as like an Easter, uh, Easter Bunny Combo.
Yeah, it's holidays. That thing is massive. Right? Susan Hollow.
They're like hollow tubes. Yeah. You think that'd be so heavy you think?
I get a lot of people that come up to me and start grabbing my chain. I'm like,
Yo, this is supposed to be a mystery. You know today that you have in mind,
you're not supposed to know what this feels like. You know, it's really like
them. The illusion that I spent like $25,000 on the vas go rope chain.
But uh Nah.
Well you remember when rampage used to where the motorcycle chain links? Yeah.
Real heavy links around his neck. I was gonna actually go, there was two routes.
I was gonna go the old school rail with my chain,
like the way my dad used to wear it and how we used to wear when we were kids or
rampage Jackson and be like the new generation of rampage Jackson.
Even though I wasn't like slamming people,
but I would have to like somehow work that of this. Yeah,
that's rampage still fighting crazy. Crazy. You know,
it's still competitive after all these years.
I mean rampage was a fucking pioneer man. Yeah.
I remember his fight with Chuck Liddell has fights with Vandelay Silva.
Even the one he lost in our pride when he went through the ropes and then he
came back and got redemption. I was like, God, that's gotta feel so good.
Cause that's like the bad highlight.
And he came back and got a highlight of his own.
So I think he lost a Vandelay twice and yeah,
he got stopped twice in pride and then flat Vandelay in the UFC. Yep.
I also think, man, it's hard, it's speculation.
But I also think that the Vandelay that he fought in UFC was the one that got
drug tested. Yup. 100% different. Vandelay yeah.
I think there's a lot of that for a lot of people too. Um, a lot I don't like,
don't like saying, I don't like saying it cause you know what it is.
I feel like I see these people and then it's like,
I know you might've heard me say this,
so it's like that little awkward tension and I don't like that man. I know.
Yeah. Yeah. You're a good guy. It gets weird.
But it is a thing that if you look at it historically,
if you look at the sport in terms of like,
like when people look at Barry bonds and when they look at Jose Canseco or when
they look at, uh, what's that other dude's name? The Dude Mark Maguire.
Yeah. Or Sammy Sosa.
Everyone knows those dudes were juice heads. That's just a part of the thing.
So you go, well, they're amazing baseball players.
Incredible athletes also were on the sauce. Yeah.
Fact does that take away from it though? That's, that's my o's. That's,
it's hard to say, right, because everybody was on it. Yeah.
Do you know there's a great documentary that's out right now by Billy corban.
He's the same guy who did a, he did cocaine cowboys one and two.
He's got a new one out about a rod. Okay. What is it called?
I gotta check that up. Screw Ball. Screw Ball.
It's hilarious. But it's about the fighter, the, the players that uh,
it was about how a debt,
how owing a roid doctor some money who will turned into this horrible revelation
where they found out how,
how these baseball players were getting their juice from that guy.
Cause they owed somebody some money. This guy and that guy didn't get paid.
So he went public with everything.
So it was like a small amount and they had a bunch of kids,
like these little kids play the doctor and play a Rod.
So like in the movie, the reenactments,
the reenactments were all done by children. That's hysterical. I'll do that.
You got to check that out. It's hilarious. It's a funny movie. This is fun.
Yeah, they, he gets really fun.
That's a rod as a child. It's fucking really funny man. Um, man,
what's it called? Just a screwball. Screwball. Yeah.
Well Billy corban is a genius. He's a really,
really great director and he, like I said,
he directed two of my favorite cocaine documentaries of all time,
cocaine cowboys one and two. Have you seen those? No. Okay.
Don't even look at screw ball yet. I haven't even seen narcos. Oh Geez.
I'm like, I'm trying to catch up. There's so much.
So much content out there is hard. Do you fuck with stranger things?
I've got to get into that too. A Guy, I just started black mirror.
I'm on season three and that just started like opening my eyes. I'm like, man,
technology is like, it could be used in such fucked up ways. It's crazy.
[inaudible] bomber was right. The Unabomber was correct. Yeah.
That show fucks me up more than any show because it's so close to possible.
Yes. Especially episode one. Season one with the pig. Oh yeah.
That was the one that got me most was crocodile.
The one where there's the,
the car accident and they hide the body and then the lady one's up doing all
these different things to cover up her crime. Now. Read People's memories.
You can get people's memories and you'd watch them play. Oh,
rewatch that one I saw freaky. Yeah. Well the one,
the lady did terrible things. Yeah. I'm like, ah. Oh. It's a seasonal way.
Oh. Oh, okay. Well I don't want to tell you anything. You're going to,
you're going to shit, but I didn't even ruin it. It's that good.
There is one though with the, with the memory. Yes. The guy and the girlfriend.
The girl's cheating. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's fucked up. Yeah. That's fucked up.
It's all coming, man. That's all coming. I've been talking about this on stage,
like how good is your memory? You know, cause my memory's not that good.
Like if I tried to remember things that happened yesterday,
if I had to draw everything I saw yesterday, it's not that good.
Like even if you say your memory's good,
it's your recollection of actual things. So you don't have a video memory.
But if you had a video memory, wouldn't it be like that's,
that would be a first thing that we surrender.
If they could put a champion second, the aljamain listen,
wouldn't it be amazing if you could pull every technique and see it exactly as
it should be done. You could see it play out in front of your head.
You could see all of your memories. All of them. Exactly. So you have no,
like if your girlfriend says, you told me, Yo don't know. I didn't say that.
This is what I said, I'll play it for you right now.
That that's gonna they're gonna. That's how they're gonna get us. Yeah.
But it's Kinda scary. And they showed it. The guy was able to freeze frame the,
the the guy's memories with his wife? Yes. And then it was like,
that's my, that's my picture in the background. And she was like, oh,
it was only like a one week thing and then it's like, oh,
do you like a one book thing that turned into like yesterday? Yeah.
That's fucked up. That was fucked up good though. Yeah.
I don't think I want that. That would be, I want it as it used to be.
I want to know, I want to know what I'm dealing with.
I think we're going to, I don't think it's, I don't think we have a choice.
I think it's common. I think it's inevitable. I'm going to rebel.
You're going to have great rebellion. I'll be the leader. Imagine if like a,
they just figured out way. I mean,
when you're thinking about people that have CTE and brain damage and car
accidents and football and fighting and all these different things,
what if they say, listen to some week, we'd fix all that,
fix all that with this chip. It
just, it rewires the whole brain. You're fine.
And it provides you with that video memory.
So you could have your entire MMA career never worry about CTE.
You could just swing for the fences like right.
Like lamas and Max Holloway did this down in the middle of the octagon swing.
No worries. Just Bang. Yeah. But then if you did that,
then what about like Parkinson's or anything like that?
Would that still be a thing? Or if that wasn't a thing, then I'd be all for it.
But also, oddly enough,
I think that part of what makes MMA so exciting is that there was crazy
consequences.
That's part of the reasons why when you see like Mazda doll knocks out.
Ben Ask for him without flying knee. Part of why I was so excited, like, oh,
he's hurt bad. It's not that he's going to be fine.
Nothing's no damage from this whatsoever. Like, no, that's real damage.
Like he went out cold instantly and then he got punched in the face twice as
part of what, it's terrible.
But it's part of what makes this sport so exciting is that you realize these
guys are so brave to face these potential consequences. Yeah, makes it,
it makes it, this is like an added element of danger that makes it exciting.
It's very true, but it's, man, I feel so bad for him when that,
when I saw that because it kind of brought back memories for myself. I was like,
ah, I know exactly what that moment feels like.
I don't remember it but I know exactly what that moment feels like.
When you fought Mariah's, do you remember what happened up to that? Yeah,
and you just don't remember it landing.
I S I saw like right before lens and it was like, you know when those movies,
when it goes, it was at this very moment he realized he fucked up.
That's exactly what that was for me and out like a light man and I didn't like
come too and like,
I mean I woke up but I didn't come to like actually remember like shit.
I was in a fist fight and I lost like really bad like really quick when I got
into the hospital and like that's when you realized, yeah,
I heard Ben say the same thing. I was like, oh, this is not just me.
I guess he's just a really bad knockout.
Him shooting forward and Mazda dog jumping into him like a car crash man and
Mazda dolls running full clip that was a 40 yard dash running full clip and
perfect placement of the knee. I mean you don't get a cleaner knockout. No.
And uh, just the way he did it,
like he was showing a video of him practicing it and saying he had like three
different scenarios of how that situation could have went.
That's like masterful thinking tactical.
Like there's not a lot of people who are that cerebral when it comes to the
game. And I think the way he broke that down,
it was just super impressive and he kind of lowered him to sleep like his hands
behind his back and I loved every second of that cause you'd want to show what
was about to happen. I was on the edge of my seat, that was my main event fight.
And then he just comes out, takes a side step,
like just drifts off to the right and at boom 40 yard dash and fly me Kale.
It was just as much a main meant for me too because it's so important for the
welterweight division. Whereas like John Jones versus Tiago Santos,
it was an interesting fight and it turned out to be a great fight,
but it was an interesting fight because you're like, okay,
how is John Jones going to beat this guy and is this guy going to be wild enough
to catch Jon Jones? But when you looked at it on paper,
John was a prohibitive favorite when you looked at aspirin versus Mazda Denali.
You like, man, I don't know. Yeah. When I looked at Holly and Amanda, I'm like,
Holly's a great champion and she's a great fighter,
but Amanda is so God damn good.
It's almost like she doesn't have anybody else left to fight.
It's not like Holly had made this incredible case for her being the one to
challenge Amanda next.
It was just that man is kind of cleaned out that bantamweight division. Yeah,
she fought one person.
She beat Megan Anderson and I felt like she struggled with that fight.
The only way she, I felt like she'd done really well when she was able to get,
uh, Megan down to the ground. But when she was in a clinic,
she ate a lot of knees. This is Holly. And then she tried to do the same thing.
The previous fight was Cyborg and she ate a lot of knees into clench trying to
slow cyborg down it, it just didn't work out in her favor.
So when that matchup was announced, I was like,
he's going to either stay on her bike the entire time and just try to appoint
fight or it's just not gonna end up good. And sure enough, that's what happened.
Yeah,
I thought she was gonna probably try to stay on her bike as well and throw kicks
from the outside. But I guess Amanda had planned for it.
That's why she caught her with her leg up. You know,
if you see the way she landed that round kick, she caught her with her leg up,
like she was like, like pressing with that sidekick and then boom,
kind of that roundhouse kicked right across the top.
And Holly's such a good girl. She's such a good person yet.
That was almost too nice. But then you feel bad for yeah,
but I know what you mean. And she, she did, she didn't make a great case,
like you said, for the title fight, but there was really no one else for her to,
there's nobody. Well,
once she beat up Raquel Pennington the way she did and then once she goes up and
destroys Cyborg, it's like who else is there?
We were at cal painting is like as tough as they come. Yeah. And she,
she was battering her. Which way she put away Ronda,
the way she put away Misha, she just smashes people. It's scary. I think it's,
it's her HSA, Vanko sideboard and then everybody else.
I think you're 100% right. And I think that's an interesting fight.
She might decide, I don't know if she can make one 25 but if she just,
I don't know, she's a big girl,
but if she decides or if she chanko decides to step up one more time to one 35
and tries to become champ champ and beat her,
I mean they had a really fucking close fight, especially that second fight.
That second fight was very, very close.
I didn't know who to even really score for it, but uh, yeah.
And Valentino made a case at the end that she thought that she had one,
but it was a very good fight.
His point is Shevchenko obviously when you see her knockout Jessica high who
used to be a top band and way contender herself,
she's one of the rare girls that like Amanda and like Cyborg can flatline women
with one shot. The scary man is scary. W those,
those ladies hit hard. Yeah.
And her kicking technique is just exemplary. You know,
Valentina is so good on her feet. Her kicking is so nasty, man.
She has one of the cleanest spinning back kicks in the sport.
You don't even see a comment. Yeah. The way she just,
I liked the way she hops up and down.
It kind of reminds me of like a little Cooper and a Mario brothers cause she's
like hop and then she move inside. Step in check, hug. Like boom, boom,
spinning back kick out of nowhere. Yeah.
It's like she's a weird combination of Moitai and karate. Yeah.
She's got traditional martial art techniques but the like rock solid Moitai too.
It's the dancing I think for system. Yeah. Things. The dancing.
Well you know that's Loma chicos secret. That's one of his secrets.
I heard amazing boxing techniques. His Dad made him dance like traditional.
I think Ukrainian dancing make. Make sure that's right.
I don't want to fuck that up.
It's like some kind of traditional rushing dancing for like four years. Yeah.
Now I heard that he made him stop boxing for a bit so that he could focus on
dancing. That's what he did for four years.
That's a crazy makes sense.
I guess the footwork and everything cause going to do that though.
If they said aljamain listen, how old are you now? Hold you.
Now I'm 30 at the end of this. Okay, 34 is your prime.
This is what we're going to do next four years. You just get to dance.
He be like, what the fuck are you talking about? Wait a minute.
The hunt for the title right now, that close that close,
especially after Henry. So Hutto just beat Marlon. Arise like, Holy Shit.
There was, well, where are we? Where are we? Yeah, this is a hole.
We got a double champ situation here, right? You've got this crazy, crazy,
so crazy. That division is wide open.
I love how much the Bantamweight Division has heated up.
It's been such a crazy ride for myself and just being a part of this and being
able to see like the wave and generations of different fighters coming in and
out. You know, I, you know, I was talking about it like El Nino,
you know Gilbert Melendez and seeing like when he was on the top and now he's
Kinda like his fight last fight. We'll all know. Alan's Kinda like,
you can just kind of see like the passing of the guard or maybe maybe he's just
not. Uh, cause I know he popped a some type of PD also,
so maybe that was something to do with it or maybe 35 I think.
Or sold six. Yeah. And Arnold Allen's 25 and fucking nasty.
So young bull. Yeah. And he's being trained by Barraza Hobie who, I mean,
I don't think there's anybody better. Yeah. In terms of trainers,
I think there's like just as good or in the neighborhood of good,
but he's the fucking man as far as I'm concerned. Yeah.
And there's just this a lot of,
there's just a lot of hot prospects just coming out.
And I know you've got the Corey stand Hagens even Rivera.
I know Rivera lost two fights in a row now, but he still is tough as they come.
He was beating PD on until he got dropped that Yup. Rounds One and two.
He won round three even having his nose busted up and everything.
Got Pyotr Yon though, man. He is a seasoned Stryker.
It's really interesting to see him with a guy like Jimmy who relies on his power
and his toughness and you know,
it was bulldog tenacity to see him get lit up in those two rounds.
And so yon just set traps and look for openings.
And then when he finally found them, he just called him rack some. Yeah,
I mean it's a really exciting division right now. Real exciting.
That might be my next fight though. Him for the belt. I would hope.
I would think that would be the next fight and I'm, I'm,
I kinda liked that match up.
He actually tried to punk me at the EPI center last week. It was kind of,
it was funny. At the same time I was like, dude, I am not really understanding.
And then on my left side I got, I'm getting worked on, I got know [inaudible],
whatever her name is, she's on my left side and she's getting worked on.
And then I didn't know there were teammates. So he comes in,
he's like the mirror he's doing like the thumb things like slashing his throat.
I start busting out laughing and I show him the bell and,
and I started slashing my throat and I'm like, yeah, you know,
I'm going to get the strap, whatever. So he, they, he comes in,
he comes in with his camera crew and uh,
it starts to go a little bit back and forth,
but I can understand he doesn't really speak English,
so I guess he said something and then she translate out of nowhere. So I'm like,
I'm getting ganged up on right now. And she's like, he says,
why are you afraid to fight him in Moscow? And I was like, Whoa,
what did I just come from? But I looked back at him like,
no one's ever told him no one's afraid to fight him. And then I thought,
I thought about it. I was like, wait, motherfucker, who is ranked higher?
You don't call the shots. I call the shots. I was like, you're not dean away.
You're not showing Showbie or you fight where I said,
you're going to fight or wherever Dana says we're gonna fight. So don't,
don't sit here and try to like act like everyone was afraid to fight you.
I'm like one, I don't want to go to Moscow to fight. That's one.
I will hopefully admit that he live in Russia.
He tr he lives in, I thinks he's from Siberia. She what? I know,
but I know he trains Taiga Moitai okay, that's right.
So he trains in Thailand and he lives or he's from the coldest,
most dangerous part of the world. Great. Yeah.
I'm not looking to go there and fight their guy and like, I mean if I have to,
I will. Is there a Moscow cards scheduled?
There was talkings of it and I think November. Oh, upcoming. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh Wow. Cool experience. But it's not,
not an ideal thing for me in terms of financial situation. Getting out there,
paying the taxes. I'm like, dude, this, that's just,
I just rather be home somewhere. Yeah. Like I don't care. Fuck worry.
If I find him in the fucking bathroom,
I would have fought him in the PII center if he was acting, you know, if he,
if he deserved it. But it is what it is. I'm like, dude, no one's afraid to,
I'm a fighter. I don't understand what fighters.
Try to intimidate fighters and make it look like it'd be fighting a cage. Right.
You know? It's like, dude, but it does work.
The thing is like fucking with people's heads is real. Yeah. This is true.
It is true. Like best example chosen,
y'all was one of the greatest fighters of all time. I really believe that.
He was out of his composure when he fought Connor and that's one of the reasons
why I charged after Connor and Connor cracked him with that straight left.
It's like Connor was in his head that he was working in the back room when he
was like, yeah, that's unreal. Unreal, unreal.
I mean he planned it out. He knew it was coming.
It's like Mazda doll practicing that flying knee against aspirin.
It's really similar. Yeah.
It's like you know tendencies and you also know emotions and he just wanted to
get at Connor so bad that he kind of knew he was coming. So you're like,
get him some faints, hot brown, throw some sidekicks, hop around,
knows he's coming back and as he's coming catches on me.
Perfect scent coming in. Like again,
similar because they're both coming at each other. Yeah.
Charging in and getting caught. Crazy car crash. But I don't think,
I don't know if he really thinks he's going to intimidate me.
I don't know if that's what he thinks or I'm to do it. He's trying it.
It's a tie. A time honored, proven tactic. Yeah.
If you get inside someone's head, they get angry and one of two things happens.
Either they fuck you up more because now they're really personal about it.
You know, like, like Mazda doll. Yeah. Or it bothers them and they lose.
Some people lose, genuinely lose their composure if they don't like a fighter.
But say that the cowboy and Nate Diaz, that was an insane fight and that was,
I think that's last time he probably ever let himself get mad. He said so,
but how's the learning experience? You know,
he realized that like that shit talking fucked with his head and you know,
but there's some guys who do better when they should talk. Yeah,
I think I perform better when there's more in the line.
Like when Pedro was talking shit to me, I didn't really understand it.
I was like, dude,
all I did was ask whatever happened with the results of your drug tests and that
turned into all fuck him. He's a bitch if he said that. And what happened?
Did he have a gay pop for something in 2015 when he was fought in Nova Scotia?
Um, it was, it, was it a diameter? It was that year.
There was like three or four guys from Black House and we made that all pop for
something. And I can't remember all the names.
I know Kevin Casey was one of them.
Pedro was one of them and I think it was like two more other guys.
I think silver might've been one of them. Yeah. And it was one more guy.
Did you ever see Anderson's trainer? No, not Jackson Dude.
He's not just Jack, he's Jack. Then he's like 68. He uh,
he's uh, he's old as the pyramids and built like a brick shit house.
This dude is fucking stacked. I mean full six pack,
giant packs arms. I got to see the wall is fuck Jamiel pull up a picture of him.
I should have doing a selfie. I mean look at that guy. Come on. Ah,
come on son. That dude is Jack Modified.
Do his absolute like a turtle shell look like a Ninja Turtle. Yeah.
Like you'd roundhouse kick him there and he would go nowhere. He left for you.
Huh? That's like a dude in 300. It comes down your head with an axe. Dude.
That's serious. So that was Anderson's trainer.
That dude is most likely aware of some Mexican supplements.
Probably like I would say so. I would say so. Yeah.
Let me come on man. That guy. Oh yeah.
Apparently a very good trainer too. So uh,
he was the strength and conditioning guy for Anderson for a lot of the black
house guys, giving them a lot of strength. It gave him a lot of strategies
to speak in a straight to here.
And Mark Coleman and Ken shamrock are on a fight in some new band knuckle boxing
promotion. I didn't even see that announcement just today. Oh my Lord.
You know, I was like, oh no, how do we save this security? Bravo send it to me.
And I just looked at that, took a deep sigh like, oh,
I don't like seeing stuff like that. It makes me sad and I it,
it makes me wonder if I'm going to be like that when I get older and I'm like,
I hope to not hope when I walk away I just fucking walk away. I hope so too.
But then again,
if they're in a situation where they need money and something comes up like this
and they're willing to do it, why do I give a fuck? Like why?
Why is it a thing where I am cool with young guys doing it if they need money,
but I'm not cool with guys that are 5,200 if they need money, like what is it?
I see your point, what I'm saying,
but it's like seeing the guy in their physical state and you're like, dude,
you should not be doing this right. So he's like, Yo, you, you're watching.
I don't know. It's almost like, I dunno. It's hard.
I don't really have an analogy for this right now.
I know exactly what you're saying though.
It's like you hope that they find a better life and they, they, they,
they hit the finish line. They're like,
thank you very much during the hall of fame and then they move on.
That's what your hope. I'm hoping that's what I do. Get the fuck out.
Some people can do it, you know, make my money.
My favorite example in all combat sports is marvelous. Marvin Hagler,
Marvin Hagler,
when he lost the sugar ray Leonard and a very disputed decision said that's it.
I'm done. Just walked away. Never came back.
A rematch with sugar ray Leonard would have been bananas.
He would've made so much money.
He was a middleweight champion and this is one fight and he's like, I'm done.
I'm going to be a movie star in Italy and moved to Italy and is never fought
again and he talks perfect. Now when you hear him talk,
he's got no brain damage or if he does, you can't tell by the way he's talking.
He sounds fine. It's probably,
I mean a lot of this stuff they say like sets in like later on in life.
So it might have been in his late sixties [inaudible] I hope to be him. Yeah.
I hope to be that guy, you know? Yeah. I try to do it. You know,
I try to do a good job of bobbing and weaving and moving my head and slipping
off the center line. We just look guys. Hicks too. You keep guys on the outside.
You have a weird style man. It's a close month. Yeah,
that's what it is. [inaudible] close about that. Go Fuck. Oh,
did you start out from a, I mean, I know you have a wrestling base too. Yeah.
What did you, what did you start out with? What was your first martial art?
I didn't have any. We, we, you know the karate come from like VHS tapes.
I Shit you not, I have a family of theirs. I think there's 20 of us now.
Your Dad, my dad just had a newborn son. I shit you not, he's 57.
The guy's out of his fucking bird. Wow. But uh, it just had any boys,
I hadn't even met him yet. That's one. And uh, all the boys grew up,
we had these karate taste,
VHS tapes and we would imitate the characters and we'll be like,
we're the drunken master or where the white tiger,
white lion and we have to do their fight styles and when I little kid,
so we're still flexible and malleable and we like don't break as easily,
so we just start beating the shit out of each other.
But we'd do like spinning back cakes,
jumping off the couches and shit like that.
And I think that might've traded like,
cause that was like we did definitely years,
but that was the most combat we did. We didn't do any like wrestling. No,
nothing traditional at all before I ever got into martial arts.
I used to do that same thing. I used to throw kicks with my friends.
I didn't know what I was doing, but it was fun. But yeah,
you like watch a Bruce Lee movie and start throwing kicks or some Chuck Norris
film or something like that. Yeah.
You learn how to do stuff by watching the beat.
You'll also develop some terrible habits. Yeah.
But you don't look like you developed any bad habits. Like if I had to guess,
I would say you have a traditional martial arts background in what?
The way you throw kicks, like you throw kicks,
like a guy who started throwing kicks when you were really young. Yeah,
but they, right. You throw them right. Which ones would you say?
Like all your shit, your roundhouse kicks, your front kicks you,
you have great front kicks, man. You're really good at keeping guys off of you.
You have good movement. You know like you're,
you got a style that's a unique style. Like so when when guys have to fight you,
they go, oh, this guy is going to be kicking at me from the outside.
He moves a lot. He bobs and weaves. It's hard to hit.
You've got a lot going on with your style. It's very tiring.
I was going to ask you that too cause we called that in your last fight.
Like the third round he were kind of slowing down a little bit.
I'm like imagine all the energy this guy's using because you're always bobbing
and weaving and moving and kicking and moving and kicking and moving and Moon
Joe's is just, you know,
Bob and towards you and and just throwing juditional type shit.
Bobbing his head too. He looked at like energy output,
like how much more energy you must've put out in that fight than he did.
Just incurrence of the amount of kicks you throw and amount of jumping back and
forth and leaping in leaping out like this. That's all like a cylon tricks.
It's a ton. And the good thing is credit to like the training that we do,
you know we get the, I get the the right work. I got that Guy,
I'm a rob Devachetti who's a freaking psycho. That guy does not get tired.
We call the machine for a reason. The Guy,
he will finish the with me and I'm like, I did my rounds, championship work.
I'm done with going get on the bike or hit the pads, whatever it is,
or band work just to get a little extra cardio push and he'll be in there and
grab two, three, sometimes full more bodies to spar with it. I'm like,
this guy doesn't fucking stop. He's out of his fucking brain.
This is no exaggeration, this guy is out of his fucking bird.
But it's the reason why my cardio, I'm like,
you want to get your cardio top notch, get yourself a fucking Mirage,
get yourself one of those do. He's a man. He's a good dude. He's a good dude.
Sometimes too much of a good deal. I'm like, Rob, I can carry,
I could carry my own wallet. You know, it's like,
it gets to the point like that. Like, dude, thank you. I appreciate it.
But you know, but um, yeah, it's a very tiring style. Um,
but we do a lot of work and I do my own start to conditioning just from having a
background in physical education and SUNY Cortland. So do your own.
Yeah so I've been doing it since I was amateur, like writing my own thing,
my own program.
Cause they told us how to like work on like isometric squeezes and different
type of like explosive muscle and dorms workouts and stuff like static holes
like holding all them on a puller bard and going out to punches. So I,
I put together a pretty decent program. It's been working, I can't complain.
So when you do it, how do you design it uses a designer for the entire camp.
Like do you set it out every day?
Like where you want to be and you adjust it depending on how you feel and
injuries. Like how do you have your schedule all that exactly like that.
So when I'm further off from the camp or not in camp at all,
I'll do more lifting and I'll lift heavy and I don't really do like benching no
more that I think that shit's like stupid for four fighters.
It doesn't make a whole lot of sense. I'm not going to bench press
somebody off my back, you know? Right. You know, I don't know whatever.
But I'll do that. And I would just to training camp and just the, the a,
the programs when I get close to the fight,
and I don't mind to like sharing this because I think guys,
they make it more complicated than what it should be.
Like I sometimes I see all this crazy shit, I'm like,
I just don't understand the whole necessity behind union that. But I'm, no,
I'm no physical strength conditioning, doctorate or anything like that.
But from what I've seen that works for me.
I just try to mimic everything that I feel in a fight and implement it into a
workout. And I figured out which ways I could do that, whether it's bands,
push ups, box jobs, wall sits, I do wall sits, get ups with two plates.
So I'm sitting down on my butt and I'll do like a technical standup and I use
the wall and I've pushed up. So it's a lot of leg works, a lot of cool work.
And two plates with two plates is fucked up.
Sometimes I come there and I can do it by myself.
In the morning I go to Loma Mae by myself, 9:00 AM and I'm like,
why am I putting myself through this?
Like it can be so much easier and more simple like just to do the other stuff,
like the plyometric stuff and which is a little, not as much impact on the body,
but this is what I enjoy. I think this was what translates to the fight.
Cause this is what I feel and I feel when I do this,
I notice a drastic difference from one sparring session to the next.
But to answer your question, like I adjusted,
I'll do if I'm my legs on fire and I feel like they really beat up from
sparring. I'll do more upper body. And then if my field,
my upper body is more beat up, I'll switch it off to the lower body.
And if I feel like I'm fresh, like I had a good week, I'd maybe identity, um,
on a Saturday and I'm coming in fresh on a Monday, I'll hit it hard.
And do full body everything and I'll give myself five rounds of pushing it,
but I separated into rounds, simulate the fight around.
So I do every single minute, but I'll do about 40 40,
depending on how far I am from the fight. If I'm like just on a train case,
I don't want to kill myself, I want to ease my way into it.
So I'll start like anywhere from like 30 35 seconds to like 50 seconds and that
ten second window or that other 32nd window is my time to recover and get to the
next station. And I'll just rep whatever I'm doing, burning out, burning out.
I'll do um, the med ball between my legs.
I'll do the foam roller in my arms and I'll squeeze it.
I'll simulate the rear naked choke and I do it for two minute intervals and I'm
just squeezing the piss out of it. And obviously you can't do it,
but you do it to failure and your arms get tight.
You switch and go to the other side and you switch your legs, you figure for it,
you scissor the legs.
So you give yourself different type of stimulation to your body to kind of
account for everything that you may possibly be in for the fight.
And you never know. It was like this fight.
I did a lot of grappling but I also did a lot of punching because I thought to
myself there might be a chance that it might be a possibility that do not get
pager to the ground.
And I was happy I didn't force to take downs cause that would've fatigued me
even more. And I was like if it comes it comes. But we did it.
I did a lot of output just burning out their arms, getting that muscle indoors,
kind of using that Floyd Mayweather structure of a workout.
Just get into the heavy bag count like high punch count in a five minute round.
And I'll do that for a couple of rounds and we did a couple of times a
week and I,
I think you implement that with the lateral foot work that we do in a cage and
just staying on your bike and having people like,
like stalk you and like just not going crazy.
But it's a control like that don't punches like hooks or that Dolan,
I'm a one two and you got to like bounce side of the side and get out the way.
So there's a lot of like,
I at least I think is practical for what you're gonna actually see when you get
in a fight. And I think sure enough,
a lot of the things we did pretty much happened in a fight.
Just your toes long squeezes. It is a great idea.
I wasn't seen cause that's something that comes up often in a fight where you
maybe got a gun,
an arm triangle or something like that and it's that close to whether you get it
or he escapes. It's like how much to squeeze, how long can you keep it down?
You know when you're caught in something and it's like you're almost kinda
tapping the guy, let's go. You're like wait a little bit long.
Squeezes a, like my friend Scott Epstein, Einstein,
he teaches at a 10th planet west La.
He's always been a big fan of slow, slow workouts.
Like he'll do chin ups like this, like super slow.
I think that's what they call it, super slow and he'll do chin-ups.
Like he's doing a chin up.
It might take him two minutes to do a fucking chin up or the entire time.
So like when you're grappling with someone's like you were trying to squeeze it
a poem in here just so that long term squeeze endurance like quicksand. Yeah,
makes sense. Because if everything is fast and exploding,
but then you get a rear naked and you have to like continue to compress or a
good team when you can to a squeeze. It's different. It's such a different,
such a different field.
It's kind of not kind of reminds me it is exactly like my Brian Caraway fight.
Although I did do three workouts on the day of that fight before the fight even
Matt told me in the back room, he was like, oh Joe,
save something for the fight. I was like, no man, I'm good.
And I was just going crazy. I was like, in my head I'm like, I did all the work,
but I just wanted to be so prepared cause I knew it was the biggest fight of my
life. I knew if I beat him and finished him,
I was probably going to get a title shot was for no undefeated coming off three
finishes. And I knew if I finished him I'm more than likely going to get,
and they lined me up too because the next week I went to Fox and I was supposed
to talk about the dominant Cruz fight versus your ifa fight,
which I went but the fight didn't go my way.
So it Kinda had like a bittersweet taste to it.
So do you think it had anything to do with the extra rounds you put in or the
extra work times? 100%.
I think if I had just done my one morning Shakeout,
1520 minutes is what I do now.
Just get the food moving through my system so that my body can get like,
just feel like it's more alive again like it does during training camp. I think,
uh,
I think that fight easily done first round or even a second cause he survived
the first, but I think the second round I think I get them out of there.
But it's just experience, you know,
learning and becoming more mature about the game and trusting your training.
Do you think that has anything to do with you training yourself?
Do you think that you've had,
if you had a legit strength and conditioning coach who's monitoring your heart
rate? Like do, are you monitoring your heart rate and all that stuff? No,
I just started doing stuff with the PII center and I tried to,
because I saw that guy, Brendan Davis, he's, he's 45 foot to beat and he's a,
he's a big, he's one 35 now, which is insane to me.
So I don't know how he makes it. That's what I said. So I'm like, dude,
if I'm going to have to be, find
these giant guys, I need to figure something out. I'm like they,
they explain how he was able to cut the weight.
Like he was running like 10 miles or something and a date,
which was insane to me. I know he was saying like some of it was like walking,
but it's all about your heart rate, your resting heart rate,
where you burn the most fat and calories or whatever you want to call it.
He's so big. When I was standing next to him,
I couldn't believe he makes one 35 it's insane. I was actually pretty upset.
I was like, fuck this guy.
Go back out to your way class and didn't he say to me, wait,
I think I asked him what he weighed in the cage.
I think he said somewhere around one 60 yeah, I don't get that big.
What does he say? I'll look up. I'll check his bananas. Man, he's,
he's so gigantic and he's what? He's like six one or something like that. Yeah.
I don't want to weight class. Yeah.
I don't want to fight a guy that's six one you've gotta I gotta.
I got the unfair advantage right now.
You take your ass back out to 45 there's a device that I've been using called a
whoop
and it measures your heart rate variability and measures your heart rate and
measure like your sleep cycle.
You wear it while you're sleeping and if they think they say that,
that's one of the things that really determines whether or not you can push hard
is monitoring your heart and on a daily basis so that you see what it's like
when you wake up [inaudible] you wake up and your resting heart rates like 40
beats per minute or something like that. If one day it's 50 you need to chill.
Yeah, that that day was maybe active recovery. Maybe just do some light drills.
Nothing crazy,
but you can't push it that day because you're already 10 so you might be getting
sick or you might be,
you might be worn out and you need to give yourself enough recovery.
I've gotten sick a lot and my last three training camps,
which is something I've never like experienced with, dealt with before.
Tonsillitis twice. I'm like this unreal.
I've never had to deal with anything like that before in my life
do with it, man.
I bet if you just had monitor your heart rate and make sure that when you wake
up in the morning it's not too high because sometimes you just say, look,
you're a fucking professional fighter man. You, you're tough. There's just no,
you have to assume,
assume that maybe sometimes you're too tough for your own good because fighters
are so fucking tough. They're not complaining about shit. They're like,
time to go to work. I'm not a pussy.
I don't feel like going to work. I'm going to work. That's my mindset. Yeah.
I even talked to Tony Ricci. He does some of this drug,
the conditioning with like Katelyn Kagan and some of the other fighters,
OCHA Sasaki and the other guys at the gym.
And I always pick his brain like whenever I have questions because I say I'm
not, this is not my field, my expertise. I just been using the same program,
just changing it up and I still work out from other people, not,
I'll ask them questions and ask them.
So for some things I could tweak within my training session, but of late,
I've been, I've been doing better with taking more days off,
like two days back to back.
There's one time I even took three days off and I was like so nervous.
Like you get in your own head like, dude,
you're taking off way too much time and sometimes ray has a way of like breaking
my balls and he'd go, I don't know. I'll show. It was like,
this is a big fight. I don't know, Julie, you're going to take another day off.
I'm like, God, don't do it though.
They'll do that too because then I feel like I know he's just playing,
but sometimes I feel like
it's hard to know if he's playing or not. I think you're being serious,
so he's so old school, he really does. Him and Matt Serra,
Ray Longo and Matt Serra in the corner of the most entertaining corner of all
time. They're the best there. Larry is the best guys.
They should have a reality show. She dumb in the corner.
Give them a fighter's instruction. Yeah, they're amazing. I'm hoping.
I'm hoping they could get some that'd be sick.
If they ever got a reality show or something with like the team.
I think that'd be fun. We've got a bunch of characters. Oh, I'm sure. Yeah.
I mean every fight camp does, right. I mean,
be an interesting person to want to do that for a living. Yeah, there they are.
Sometimes I would just listen to the eye.
Looks like listening to the feedback so I can hear them screaming in the corner.
You could just hear Matt going off like,
yes, our job. That shit. Oh Joe, show who you are.
It was never there in the corner together. I always say, oh,
just tell the guy in the boot, go, go, go to Sarah and Longo. Go, go, go.
I'm going to want to hear them, dude. That last one was great. Uh,
the ESPN guys,
they posted like a little clip of them in the corner when Matt comes in and Ray
comes in, he's like, fuck yeah. Joe Is like, dude, I got pumped up.
And they tweeted something like,
get yourself a corner like Matt and Matt and ray best. That was the best.
They're amazing people. They're just, they're just great guys too. You know,
there's so many great corners now.
It's really interesting to see the sport evolve.
And that's why when you get a bad corner, it stands out like a sore thumb.
When someone gets bad advice,
they don't get good technical advice or they don't get honest advice in their
corner. It's like, wow.
And all the other fighters get the chance to see that that's your advertisement,
right? Like when you're like, for us a hobbies,
like probably one of my all time favorites. We should have these.
He's really abusive. When you hear him in the corner between rounds.
In many ways it's an advertisement to go train at his gym.
If you're a top fighter, cause you hear him talk,
he's so technical in his description.
He's so aware of what should happen and when it should happen.
Then he just knows what to do and when to do. And it's like,
that's excellent advice. Yeah. Jamie, shut your mic off
here and you're fucking rapper. You don't, your Mike's got beyond this.
That loud.
I heard it too. I did hear it. What are you doing man? What's that made out of?
Paper chips. That was a rapper made out of a potato chips. Um,
yeah, it's like a corner is in many ways just the advertisement for the gym.
So you, when you hear you're winning, you're winning, you're definitely winning.
Just go out and box. I'm like he's not winning like we in the corner.
Like that is not good advice. It's not,
and my thing is you got to give some type of instructional feedback,
something to correct or something to do better or encourage them to keep doing
the same things that they're doing or something.
Something where there's instruction. Not like get up. Oh really?
You think I need to get up? I think I know I need to get up,
but like how the hell do I get up with a weirdest shit?
Was Diego Sanchez Oh dash centers in his last fight.
I don't know who we trained with. He left Jackson Winkle.
Winkeljohn I don't know if he had training partners. I don't know what he did.
I feel the one guy in his corner telling him be like Tyson,
go out in there and be like Tyco fucking wait. He said,
I'm just giving a weird advice. Oh Diego was getting,
Michael Cassa was just full blowing on him. Yeah.
Cause flowing and every time Diego was able to capitalize on a position,
like a uh, a slip up or and window of opportunity to get on top.
He just fucked it up and then got right back up. Created a scramble and,
and he was right back in a dominant position once again. And I was like, yeah,
this is not gonna end. Well I thought he was gonna get the finish. But Dude,
the way you saw like Diego Sanchez manhandled Mickey Gall crazy.
Then the way you see Michael [inaudible] man handled Diego Sanchez.
He levels wow levels and size key essa.
It is in case you want to talk about the guy would cut too much weight.
It is incredible that that dude ever made a 155 pounds. He's so large.
That is a big man big. And when you put your hand on, I'm like I'm interviewing,
it's like a fucking piece of wood man. Yeah.
That's some grappling constrictor strength, you know. Yeah.
He's a big dude man.
I saw him before the fight in the PII sends out like to it and I told him the
same thing. I was like, dude, I don't know.
I really do not know how the fuck you ever made one 55 it's like probably
counterproductive for you to even go down there cause you just got such a big
frame. You, I think he would excel at 70 I think so too.
But what's interesting is like he's done way better at 70 than Kevin Lee has and
Kevin Lee beat him at 55 yeah.
So it's crazy how like you got to go up and wait,
but you also got to do it the right way.
I think he did it the right way when he's at one 70 he's super healthy. Yeah.
Strong dude, man.
So fan fit any flows like the way he was flown with Diego,
he just, he didn't like tighten up. He was in total control.
He would take chances, he would roll into crucifix positions.
He would lose it and get ahold of him again. Again, take them down.
It's like it was like a black belt roll in with a blue belt.
That's what it was like. I was like, wow, this is crazy to y or purple belt.
Crazy to watch. It's different man.
It's really levels to the game and it's also size.
Size to waist one 69 like the day before the fight wasn't,
didn't have to cut any weight at all.
Whereas kiss or probably would in the one nineties you were huge.
I wonder what makes him want to go down to 55 they didn't.
That's not as easy to go down to 55 this is Jamie. This is Voodoo coach. Oh,
this is coach. That would be do Sanchez this corner. No one else.
This dude has no experiences in MMA coach by the way. So this is,
the dude is telling them to be like Tyson. He's being like water right now.
You just got to slip the slip, Bro. Well touch but touch. But Diego,
such a strange guy, man.
He might believe that this dude has mass magic powers because he's,
he was talking about,
but I think a big part of Diego's success is his belief system,
right? Diego just believes things. Dude, this guy's amazing. What technique?
Oh, come on son. Show me that. Oh, knocking people out bro. Good.
Imagine looking at this guy and you go, listen, Fuck Longo and Sarah.
That's where I need to be. That would be that.
I would actually be a good like skit. Like Yo, I'm going out to train.
Like just had the whole thing leading up to it and then let them know like, Oh,
I'm just fucking around. You know?
But I think that's what Anderson Silva did when he brought in Steven's a gall
complete joke. I'm like, people were buying it.
Well, well gall was selling it. He was selling it, you know? It was like,
that's a technique that I taught Anderson brow.
Everybody knows that one j one white belt class.
Oh Man. That I can't believe people bought it for so long.
It's almost like the Ronda Rousey's did too. There he is. Look at this. Oh,
karate. Chad's the head son.
Imagine these dudes standing there while he practices all this shit.
There's George George. They all had to do with a straight face,
like you understand? It's like the ultimate troll. Look, Anderson's practicing.
It is acting so good though. My God, this is like a, you know what this is like,
this is like,
like a breakthrough circus clown given Dave Chappelle comedy technique.
Like some dude who has a, it's like a, Hey Scott,
you gotta get a nose [inaudible] and he was like, okay. Haha.
It's really what it's like.
It's like Dave Chappelle getting comedy technique from a clown that reminds me
of the Napoleon dynamite when he's like,
would you want to get kicked by me and his pants? Break the wrist.
Walk away. Yeah,
but the thing is Seagal was a legit at Quito specialist. I'll give you,
it was just,
I [inaudible] like that's what people like just because the guy seemed kind of
silly.
You forget like he had a real legit history with a key though.
He was the first American to ever teach at a Dojo in Japan.
Speaks fluent Japanese and he's a legitimate IQ master,
like 100% absolute legitimate Akita master. The thing is I,
Kido is just not something that translates perfectly to a,
to MMA. What is it? Seagal Best Akita with Russian National Akiko team.
Yeah, Bro. I'm not bullshitting man. His Eye Quito is 100% legitimate,
but you see, I would have,
I would like almost discredit everything just based on that one parody thing.
Know a joke. That shit show of a joke. Yeah,
but I mean break the wrist walk away, but this is all nonsense.
Someone's going to give you their armor, but if they did,
he would fuck you up better than this because this is Seagal.
As an older man who's overweight, go to Steven Seagal when he was really young.
There's black and white footage of him teaching at a Dojo in Japan. There it is.
He is 100% legit and Aquino's not the best martial art for self-defense.
It's just not. But it has its applications and in its applications,
he's a master at it. Much like Jujitsu has its applications,
but it's not great for kickboxing. Right. Taekwondo has its applications,
but it doesn't work if you kick the legs and punched the face. Yeah,
but if you learn how to do it, those techniques can apply.
If you know all the other stuff. Well, if you know all the other stuff,
this motherfucker has some real shit.
It's just whether or not you'd have to be so good at all the other stuff that
you could utilize. This [inaudible]. No.
Obviously he's showing in this technique he's showing knife defense and stuff
like that, but this is all 100% legit technique.
He's good man. I mean, not good. Not Good. He's outstanding. He's like,
Quito is outstanding. The real question is how effective is I? Quito.
I'm still like,
I can't get past the jokes of the front kick and this is how I get past that
part. Well, it's hard. I didn't know this. I didn't know this.
It's hard to get past someone who doesn't have an objective understanding of how
people view them. You're like, I just,
me and George St Pierre Jordanian pier wanted to learn how to throw a turning
sidekick for me. You're an animal at that, by the way.
I felt embarrassed teaching them. No, because I'm just a comedian and I'm a,
you know, I'm a commentator. But I was like, I know this sounds crazy,
that really know how to do it. And then when I did it, he was like, Holy Shit.
I was like, yeah, this is what I used to do. So, but, but me showing them that,
I mean I'm under no illusion that I could kick George Saint Pierre his ass.
He would fuck me up every day of the week. But I was like,
I have this one thing that I can show you that I bet you can't do the way I
could do it and I can show you how to do it. But I'm not like, you know,
like with Savalo's doing like that's a front kick man.
I know I was gonna throw up front kick, you know, and even a spinning back kick,
you can teach someone that. But having them,
having the confidence to confidence to execute that, to choose to do that.
Like you're in a situation that guys can forth, you choose to spin,
you gotta be so rock solid with your understanding of that technique,
you're not going to get that without years and years and years and years and
years of drilling it.
That can be a death sentence in a, in a live combat fist fight. Yeah.
So even like when I throw sometimes I'm like, man, I do a lot of shit man.
Like I do like the tornado kicks and shit now. And uh,
and I do like I did one time to Pedro on this fight where he came at me and I
stepped back and I did like a hopping, spinning back kick,
like the one you ride a hole, hit a gay Guy Musashi. Oh yeah, I did that.
But it hit him like right on the belt, not exactly where I wanted to hit to a,
to land and a pitcher, my foot slides down,
it looks like I kicked him in the balls, but it was like right above,
like the belt line. I was like, aw man,
if I just got a little bit more to the side and I with the heel I would've
probably dropped. You practice that like in front of the bag. Oh yeah.
But then I will have someone holding the shield and can,
I'll just go for like 20 minutes.
I just have it like controlled like I'm like Yo,
cause I want to have like a stationary target but also somewhat moving.
So it was more practical cause no one's just going to stand in front of you and
be like, Hey, just spinning back, kick me to the ribs all the way.
I learned how to do it with swing you [inaudible]
bag. I would swing a bag. Then the bag was coming close to me.
I would jump up in the air and spin and stop and do it that way.
The only fight that I have from taekwondo at all was me winning by knockout with
a jump spinning back kick one on Youtube. Yeah.
That's the only one where I was like 19 Jamie could probably find it.
But that technique, if you do it right, if you do it right,
it's fucking devastating.
But you open yourself up whenever you turn and you spin. Especially.
So I'm doing an and talk one. No, well you can't punch to the face. It's,
it's less risky. You can't kick to the legs. You can get away with it more.
You can't punch it at face, but you could kick to the face kick to the face,
which is ridiculous. What do you got? What happened? Oh, here,
this is me when I'm 19 Ooh, that's you. Yeah, that was me.
But it's like the same thing,
like he's coming forward and I caught him as he's coming forward, but that,
that technique in MMA mean if you've got like Valentina does it better than
anybody. She does it. You don't even see it.
Common Valentina Shevchenko throws for that guy climbed.
If you hit somebody with that, it's like getting hit by a car. I mean,
that's what I was telling George. I was like, if you do it right, your,
your weight is going towards it. The problem with the way most people do it,
they're hitting it and bouncing off of it.
You're not even like going all the way through it. You're not following through.
They're going bang like that. They're hitting it and going back, I'm saying go,
go kick through it. Your weight should be going through it and it seems awkward,
but once you develop the technique and do it properly, it's not awkward.
It's the best way to do. And you get so much weight going forward.
That's another problem I have and I was talking about this earlier today with
some of the guys. Um, uh,
like I normally try to like rewatch all my fights and then take like a notebook
or my phone and jot down notes and things I could do better or things that I
think I fucked up or I want to clean up that type of stuff. And, um,
one of the things I'm noticing, I mean I've, I've noticed it for a while,
but now I think that's gonna be like the next evolution of my game is sitting
down on my punches and my strikes more so that it has more of my body weight
behind it. Cause I punch a lot and transition and it's cool. It's fancy,
it's hard to hit. I'm super loose with that way. But again,
like we were talking about minutes, a lot of the work rate is just high.
You got to be constantly moving, but it's fun to watch.
Do you think you're going to stick with doing all your strength and conditioning
yourself or do you think you will move to like a professional like strength and
conditioning group? I mean, as you move into five rounders too. Yeah, right.
Well I trained for five round fights when I was doing this too.
But I mean obviously the level of competition was in the same round that was on
the regional circuit before I came up. And I mean,
I had success in training while I was sparring with five different bodies,
five different individual rounds, you know, and I,
and I did pretty good in terms of my cardio,
but I was also a young bull back then. Now I'm a little older,
so I still think I'm a young bull, but it's a difference when you're 21,
22 compared to 29 even though, you know,
I think I'm right now on my prime years getting into also,
you're aware of like all the damage you're doing to your body all the time.
Yeah. Where you're 21, you barely aware of it. I just, you just go nuts. Yeah.
Your brain's not even fully formed.
This strong kicks and punches and going crazy. Yeah. But I, I mean, maybe,
I mean that totally Ricci Guy at the gym, he's pretty, he's pretty good.
He says,
I feel bad taking up his time because he helps out so much and volunteer.
So of his time I feel bad
because, uh, it's not like I'm, I'm not, he doesn't really,
he doesn't ask for money. So it's like,
I feel bad if I'm not paying you for your service.
I don't like it doesn't ask for money. Nah, not Tony. Not from the,
not from the fighters. You know,
he has some money he likes just seeing like the local guys do well and he likes
helping out. That's amazing. Yeah. He's a professor.
I forgot the school he's a professor at, but I'm really, really smart dude. Uh,
I know he goes down to the PII center from time to time to like, uh,
I think share some knowledge and learn some stuff from those guys as well.
So maybe, maybe I'll go that route.
It would be nice if I was able to train at the PII center.
You have the entire staff on hand. Like Oh God, those guys,
that's such a thought about doing a camp there. I mean if you did,
what do you think Longo and Sarah would be interested in doing that or they
know, right? They really can. They can, they got family, they got the kids,
they got their gyms. Yeah. I always tell them like, Yo,
can we like move to like somewhere warmer? Like a Florida or something. No,
no state tax. You know, bring the whole team, bring the whole team,
bring the whole family, we'd get a bigger house.
They don't want those little shacks, those Long Island dudes. Man,
they got roots. I know that. That's what it is. Very. It's like
I got money, he's got everything here. You know, they both do.
They were so used to their community too. It's like that's their family,
their friends, everybody's there. All the guys who come to the gym, it's like,
yeah, I get it, I get it. But man, if you're a professional,
it seems like every little edge that you can get can mean a little bit of
something.
And that performance institute is a real edge that places amazing.
Well, I look at it like I got my striking from Ray.
I got my Jujitsu for Matt and all the other guys,
Jason around those guys and the Henzel Jim will not,
if I go to Hensley's in the city. And then I had the wrestling,
my own background. And then, um, you know,
I teach the wrestling classes at the gym and then I go down to harsher sometimes
and I bought some of those guys, some of the,
I mean did not like the Penn state,
but there's still a solid rustlers and all that.
They give me pretty damn good word compared to what a lot of the wrestling looks
like in a may now. You know, so I'm getting solid work there.
I think the main part is my nutrition and I, I really don't sleep.
I have my sleep. I'm so fucked up. I really don't sleep. I mean,
I'll send me the CBD helps me to most, but everything else,
unless I'm like hammered and I just pass the fuck out. But then I'm like, dude,
I'm like fucked up the next day. You know? That sounds like counterproductive.
Totally counterproductive. Yeah. Have you heard of that chill pad? No.
This is something I haven't tried but mark Sisson is who's a, he's the guy from,
he wrote that book, the primal primal blueprint and um,
he's a like a nutrition expert and he was a former endurance athlete but he's a
giant believer of this thing where you put it as like a mattress pad and it
chills your body to a certain temperature.
You could set it for whatever temperature makes you most comfortable.
But apparently he said it is a game changer in terms of your ability to sleep
through the night. Like I woke up in the middle of the night last night,
I must have been having a crazy dream. I was sweating like a pig and I woke up,
man, I'm drenched with sweat. I'm like fuck, why am I so sweaty?
Like what's Fuck's wrong with my brain? But with this apparently when you keep
you at a chilled temperature,
you just snooze and he said he sleeps hard. What do you got? I got that bad.
It is, it's coming down and chill. Pass. I don't have it yet,
but we'll be here by the time I get back into another show and have a review for
you on how it works. Amazing. Yeah. So you ordered one full bed though.
It's not just a pad,
like literally there's a tube that got like an air conditioner to goes into the
mattress and it's connected to an app and it can regulate your body like a sleep
number. But this one is called like eight sleep I believe. Or sleep aids.
The same thing very yet. Same thing. So this is the actual mattress itself? Yep.
So how much is that thing? Not It's, I looked at the prices.
I was surprised that it was not as expensive as I would think it would be.
Especially compared to like I heard this past day,
she bought one of those like a sleep number bed. Yeah. It was crazy.
I'm funny as fuck by Micah that last episode.
Oh my God. It starts at 2000 bucks I guess,
which I probably goes up depending on size, but they give it to you for free.
I do have a promotional offer, I believe. Shit. Jamie,
working in the promotional game.
I don't have a coat or anything to give anyone that's, I don't have a bed.
Why not? I have a test. I have a pullout couch.
What do I have a very unique way of thinking once you're a top bantamweight
contender in the fucking UFC, it's fucked. How do you sleep?
He's sleeping on a pullout bed. Yeah. What?
Aljamain that's outrageous. You need to be able to sleep.
No wonder where you have a problem sleeping. Well,
I feel like I still always had the problem I got,
I think I might have sleep apnea by smile. My girlfriend Rebecca, she's,
she's had me, she's recording me like, oh my God. I was like,
yeah baby, you just got to deal with it.
You just gotta deal with it or do you have it dudes with big next kid?
I have it a thing that I put a mouthpiece in that I got from this guy.
Does your Caribbean. It pushes my tongue down. No,
the mouthpieces like sits on your bottom and it's got like a tongue,
like someone like touching your tongue, pushing down on it.
And it keeps my tongue from sliding back your throat and it's hovering over my
air hole. Okay. So how, how much I want to, cause I, I mean I got,
I just got one from a dentist that I'm working with and um,
he has the one that pulls your bottom jaw forward like these bands.
Is it helping you? It's been helping but um,
it's just my jaw just really tight in the mornings. I'm like,
oh that's not good. Then you gotta wait for like,
like half an hour for it to kind of reset and adjust back. But man,
being able to sleep,
I felt like I could be so much more efficient with my day cause I always hit
that mid day question, which I'm not sure if that's normal, but I wake up,
I have the most energy cause like I'm just taking a bunch of power naps because
I wake up so many times in the middle of the night with this accompanied that I
know that sells them that you could just buy and it's like a boil and bite
mouthpiece ton of thing and it has a bar that keeps your tongue from sliding
back. That's what you use? No, this is different
one. There's a couple of different ones.
There's a couple of different versions here and I don't know which one you want
to. I never seen these different ones or these are different.
There's one that I'm here, I'll, I'll pull it up real quick.
This one goes around. Your tongue looks like a pacifier as real world looking,
but it looks really weird. Yeah, it was like a octopus. [inaudible] octopus.
What's those things? Jellyfish. That's weird.
I don't think what you're saying about that. Like you bite down on that.
Now there's one that's different. Hold on a second. I'll find it here.
I'll go into my old.
This one is the one I guys mold it to my teeth and in the bottom jaw just gets
pulled forward. So when I just relax my jaw,
my tongue is not like fought like it's not covering my, my airway.
It's a really conscious thing with guys who are like football players and power
lifters and wrestlers. You Develop, oh, here it is Jamie. It's a, Oh,
hold on one second. It's called a z. Y p.
A. Z much. I've heard that by further. Z. Y P p. Z.
Y p. P. A. H. Is it two p's or one p? One,
two PS. [inaudible], z. Y. P. So that's it.
So you see that thing there that has that band.
That band sorta lays on your tongue and it keeps your tongue from sliding back
and then you breathe out of the top and bottom.
Just like an over under mouthpiece. I'm trying to like envision this right now.
It's just keeping your tongue from sliding back. That's,
that's how it helps you know there's be end at the bottom, the band,
the back. That's what it is.
I remember I went to a dentist and they tried to tell me like, yeah,
we can get you a mouthpiece for like five grand. I was like,
get the fuck Outta here dude. Some guy in the city and my friend,
my friend is the one who connected me with him. It's like, yeah,
this guy's going to do right by you. As the guy told me five pants like, dude,
get the fuck out of here. Five grand for a mouthpiece. That's so crazy.
And then he made me two mouth guards and they were both shit. Anyway.
He was like, oh he mighty mouth guards. I don't want to bash you.
Let me not bash this guy, but well shout out to the mouthpiece guy.
He made mine. You guys awesome. Yeah, he's got a Instagram page.
We do shark factors as your book. Oh, he makes it
[inaudible] definitely has sleep apnea. The size of him do.
I can't imagine what's Shaq snoring sounds like
be a reality show and you can fall asleep in the row.
You wait for shack to sleep and then you gotta go in the room. It falls like,
think about how long would it take you for a, if it was like a game show,
like if Shaq is owl coke,
no way.
And you gotta lay next to him and it's like a time or ready go falsely across
sleep. I'm tired. I'm not going though.
And he's 800 pounds and he's 17,000 feet tall and he's laying next to you yet
it's just not happening. It's not happening.
That would be a whole Arius like fear factor type show.
Try and fall asleep next to shack.
Could end up in a hotel room next to him and play that game on accident.
Accidentally make those walls shake and hear the chandelier's Klingon every time
you breeze out. [inaudible] Queensland Clink Lincoln. Yeah. Yeah. Giants.
Dudes like him. He must have a crazy
snore Andre. The giant is probably like, yeah,
must be means Yo Ming.
That stuff takes away so much from your recovery because if you're snoring and
you're not getting the proper oxygen in,
you know this Dr Caribbean that I go to,
he puts this thing in your mouth and he has you breathe in and out.
It actually literally measures the output of your breath,
like how much comes in and comes out and he devised this thing to hold your
tongue in place to open up your airway.
Almost like a resting field to Max kind of thing. Yeah, similarities.
Yeah, and some guys wind up getting up.
I know a couple of guys have gotten an operation where they open up your throat
hole better and they remove your tonsils and they remove your adenoids and that
opens up the area. Yeah.
They literally get their fucking neck operated on.
They cut some of the meat out so that you have more, more air. I want to,
how does that work in terms of being an athlete? Like would that be,
you definitely wouldn't be able to get choked for a long time. I find that,
fuck me up for a long time.
Imagine someone getting you in a guillotine after you've had your tonsils and
adenoids and all that shit. You'd be months, months afterward.
We'd be able to really train hard, I would imagine. Yeah. Maybe I'll heal up.
Not going to do that. Maybe I won't go that route. But if it works.
But the thing is like, doesn't your tonsils,
don't they play a part in your immune system? I don't know.
I mean they're there. They're just hanging out. I did not like an appendix.
Right. They're there for a reason. It's not like a,
a leftover vestige of a different time. And people get it removed to,
yes. What Jamie [inaudible] part of the [inaudible]
immune system. A location at the back of the throat.
Stop Germs from entering the body through the mouth or nose. Nice.
And they contain blood, wiped a lot of, lot of white blood cells.
I need those. Yeah. So maybe just get a mouthpiece,
but yeah. Well I got this guy, this Guy Andrew,
he's making these new dental mouthpieces. Um, it's like,
it's called dental impact. So it's supposed to help you for like MMA fight,
supposed to have like a little extra cushion for you cause you know the,
you ever have you ever tried the double padded mouthpiece and it had like that
little slit and you're supposed to be expected to breathe through that.
But once you open your jaw, the mouth piece falls out.
So this one is supposed to have like a little bit of a layer,
like a gel where you bite into it and it helps like almost like pull the jaw
forward so it gives you like a little bit more room for impacts so you could
bike down. And I think it's going to just be better for like combat.
I haven't tried it yet.
He supposed to send me one so I could try it out like and give some feedback and
see how it all works. It used to be a company shock doctor.
Are they still around? Um, I know they do like cups and shit like that.
I think there was like a shock doctor mouthpiece that had the same, um,
the same idea behind it. But I was super skeptical. Oh, there it is. Yeah.
Shock doctor. But I think there's real science to that.
Look at that fucking thing. What is that shit? It's like lip guard.
The mandible man for like football players usually use that
[inaudible] shield. Oh, lip guard. Oh, so you don't get your mouth,
your lips busted. But there's a, what's that?
Airflow one screwed up a little bit there. The white one. What does that say?
Max Airflow. Football Mouth Guard. Huh? That looks stupid.
Let's air through the middle. I get the whole, yeah,
but that's fine with football. That's not fine for a five minute round.
It looks small. You know what I mean?
Like it doesn't the hole get to like go all the way. Well, the part you bite on,
right, right, right. It's not a far enough back. Dig into it.
Like what are you biting on? Just the top part with your first few teeth.
But I think they used to have these kinds of things and they were making some
claims, maybe not shock doctor, but maybe another company.
I think it was another company that was making a claim to do it.
Allow you to take shots better reduce concussions.
I think it has something to do with the that those two like nubs on top of the
jaw, the mandible bone like I guess it looks like clips to nerve and that's what
shuts the lights off in the brain. What does that one that says Fang?
Double braces. Scroll back up for brace. Like people have braces. Oh is that,
I always want it, cause my daughter had braces and she was going to Jujitsu.
She get choked and her mouth would get cut off with a bunch of holes in it.
Not just one big one. Oh, you know a lot of Russell's without,
if you have braces and wrestling in high school,
you're not allowed to compete unless you have a mouthpiece.
It's like a new rule that should, they should,
they shouldn't be allowed to compete without mouthpieces anyway.
You don't wanna fuck up your lips.
Even now when I wrestled and I bite down when I'm shooting sometimes and I get
my jaw like smashing into my teeth, I like poke steps. I'm like, yeah,
tips on my teeth that way. Yeah. It's not good now. I wear mouthpiece always.
I always wear a cup too. And I wear a cup cause uh,
I got meat in the Dick once and my dick was bleeding. Ah, yeah.
Again, my friend Scott Epstein, Einstein, same dude, he goes past my garden,
just an accident, slammed his knee into my Dick,
flatten my dick out on the Dick.
It's just sometimes it happens where it's like you zig, they zag pop.
And when I took my jock off at the end of the Roland,
there was blood in my jockstrap. I'm like, oh no. Was He,
where are you guys drilling? Are you going to lie? Cause if you truly live,
we're going live. It just understands it. Then it was just an accident.
It's just shit that happens. But it was,
if I had it now I wear one of those diamond MMA cups.
You ever fuck with those are the compression shorts.
So here's my thing with those guys, and I was going to say something earlier,
but I didn't want it to, I just don't think one cup fits all. I just can't see.
Trying to say Dick's too big. I understand. I understand. Algo.
My crotch. She just, the dye becomes too big for my crotch, man.
They make it like chiefs. It's like it's not comfortable and I tried it.
I was like, dude, maybe I'm wearing it wrong. I tried it upside down. It's like,
just be making different sizes. They told me no dude is one size fits all.
I'm like, dude, this just doesn't make any sense. Wait a minute, wait a minute.
What Franchising Cano, Francis and Ghana and Henry.
So Hutto once I seen a cop get in the fuck Outta here,
that's what they told me. That you say that's not even possible. Yeah,
they not right. They've come up to like the fight events.
I've actually seen him in uh, Chicago. I saw him in Chicago again,
like handing out like samples and stuff and he asked me like,
how did you like the cup? And I'm like, yeah, I don't want to be a dick.
I don't like being a mean guy. But you asking me this question,
I feel like I got to tell you the truth. I'm like, aw man, just didn't like it.
He was like, oh, what was wrong with it? Told me I was like,
one size just doesn't fit all. I just always, that's what I told him.
I was like, it just doesn't fit. It's too big. It's too big down there.
You don't want something that's comfortable so he could kick and lift your leg,
squeeze your legs together and Nah man,
that's just going to be crushing my sack all over the place. I get it.
Well for me it fits perfect, but I get it. Everybody's small guy,
different size junk area and if you have fat or thighs too, right?
Like white dudes with like, you know, giant like Sean Jordan,
guys with giant thick ass legs. Like how are you going to get, you know?
Yeah it's going to rub against it. But those,
the compression shorts would help with that.
Cause that's the whole idea is that instead of like the way everybody used to
wear it was just like a jockstrap. Right?
You'd have a cup in the jockstrap and it kind of floated around like I remember
in a Taco on don't turn him around,
got kicked in the balls once and my cups slammed into my nut. Uh,
and I was convinced,
I was convinced my balls were useless after that cause my shit swole up like two
times the size it should've been and it was all purple and I was like,
I broke my balls.
Did you have to get it drained or did you just like go down these?
I was 18 I didn't do it. God, I didn't do it. God,
I think I jerked off to make sure it worked once it still worked.
I'm like, we're good. Have it.
That's what I did after I started broke my Dick. I weighted that.
Not a beat off too, just to make sure it worked. I were like, we're good,
we're good.
There is funny man that looks like chicken embryos and my toilet bowl,
my baseball coach, gender, like
it just came out. Piss came out bloody too. I piss blood for a couple of days.
That's the worst pissing blood. Well, I knew it was all just dick blood.
I was just like,
the moment I feel like any sort of infection or it feels like it's sore,
it didn't hurt. So I was like, I'm not going to be nervous.
I'm going to treat it like my nose. I'm like,
I don't want my nose to fall off either, but if my nose is bloody,
I don't freak out. So I didn't want to freak out if my dick was bloody unlike,
let me just treat it like it's a normal thing. Just don't,
don't freak out. And it was fine. It's like a northern line in the room.
Don't freak out. Keep moving. If I'm pissing blood, I'm freaking the fuck out.
I know. I was a little freaking out. It wasn't like I was not nervous at all,
but I W I was trying to rationalize and I was saying, okay,
this is no different than my nose.
If my nose was bleeding right now and I ran to the hospital,
freaking the fuck out, it'd be a bitch. Right, right. Oh, can we type this?
You knows big bloody a lot. Get Dick.
You got gotta need that for some things. You definitely do. I definitely wasn't,
I mean I wasn't ignoring it. I was like,
the moment it feels like if my nose was infected, I'd probably walk it off it.
My Dick is infected. I am going straight to the ER. Um, man,
it's dangerous man. Infections are fucking dangerous.
They scared of shit on there anywhere. Infections are terrible.
A football coach today,
I guess he publicly stated he would cut his dick off for a super bowl win. Oh,
don't say it.
That didn't end up going to have the female Superbowl league when the female NFL
comes along. You could, you could join up. You could be a champ.
It's nowadays you can just do that.
You can just decide I'm a woman and I'm a champion.
Someone make that argument that they said Dennis Robbins should be considered
like the first NBA player, gay player. No, he's still,
it was Dick [inaudible] bangs girls.
He doesn't even pretend to be addressed or cross, I guess. I don't know,
cross dresser, but even that's like more for show. He does it for fun. You know,
he's still big to be doing all that shit. How crazy is that?
He's just to North Korea. He friends with a dictator.
They fly him over there.
He's playing basketball with that dude partying with them and even giving them
advice on like how to get along with Trump and everybody should get along. Yeah,
I guess. I mean, if it's working, they're not going to bomb us and shit.
He was my favorite dude. Him and uh,
Eric Roberts were my favorite dude on celebrity rehab because neither one of
them had a real problem. Like Eric Roberts would smoke weed,
so he stopped smoking weed. He's, you see him every morning.
He's fucking reading the newspaper and drinking coffee to no problem in the
world. Fucking Dennis Rodman's on the treadmill.
He's running miles and she's a professional athlete man. So he's not drinking,
he's not partying anymore. He likes to party. Was he going to live forever?
If he doesn't party, then Eric Roberts smokes a little weed.
What's the big deal? So both of those guys on that show with like,
I don't see the problem. You guys are okay. Like really cute.
Can you check again? Briden's doing miles on the treadmill.
Everybody else is going through seizures,
detox and they're freaking the fuck out. And Rod was there sweating. Whew.
Get it in. Yeah, he's fine. As funny. That is funny man.
How crazy is it that the Kim Jong wounded loves him?
That's a weird relationship at work. There's a lot of guys who live there.
He is Pardee. Not Crazy. The guy loves basketball, man. Crazy.
What happened to his lip though? Rodman yet doing a bunch of stuff.
Putting Barb's and stuff. No,
but it looks like something happened like it got bit by like a rattlesnake or
some shit. You know what I mean? Shit. Swollen. Well,
he's always had big lips and then on top of that he's got a hole in it.
Look at that fucking hole that, that ring that's pushing down on his lip.
That's crazy. But I feel like when he was in his prime years in the NBA,
it didn't look, his lips didn't look like that.
They looked like burnt out look like if it looks infected.
I think that Barb makes it look crazy. They're crazy. Yeah. Crazy,
crazy earth. I think it's like that picture right there.
Look at Trump with his lips and it's like a fucking witch lip.
Would you have for the rest of your life, do you have any trees
of like weird downturn lips?
Gigantic infected lips on little tiny tiny tiny lips. Yeah,
I don't know. That's a hard call.
It's a hard call if you have to take who's look for the rest of your life?
Kim Jong Moon.
I'm going to go with Rodman cause he at least sees a professional athletes.
Got a great body, you know
[inaudible] well it's weird when dictators get really into athletics, right?
Like that Chechnyan guy sends a lot of MMA fighters out.
I heard you talking about this. Yeah,
why they was telling us the story that guys like nuts. I heard,
oh I'm sure he's nuts. Like he likes, he said he talked,
I don't know if this is like okay to talk about or not, but he thought powerful,
powerful man. Yeah. But he said he liked Andrew's powerful man. He told that.
He told why me to like fight the other guy.
And it was like dead serious about it. I don't know if they like had a, I don't,
I think he figured out a way to like get out of it or something.
And then like one of his guys,
I think it was either one of his guys or very doom fight either Verdugo Duma,
one of his guys. I think that's what he says. Something crazy like that.
I was like, Yo Bro, tonight's pay him to do it. Ah Huh.
I think so, but it was kinda like one of those like just super powerful.
Just kind of like what he, he gets what he wants, you know? Holy Shit.
It's like, dude, you, that's like something, get the fuck out it.
Enter the Dragon Shit. Right. He flies out to an island.
You fight,
fight and he sits there in his fucking giant throne. That's crazy.
Asking people to fight. Yeah. Yeah.
I guess if you're that rich and that powerful,
you can kind of get away with that. But it's happened before.
We've had dudes out there and they made an agreement. All right,
let's fucking fight. Just go after it. Right.
There's stuff like that makes me nervous to go to places like that. I'm like,
I just came here to enjoy the culture, not to do all this extracurricular shit.
Imagine if you can go to Moscow and you knock out pure true Yan. Oh,
I'm running the fuck out in it then.
Then Putin wants you to come over [inaudible] come [inaudible] come over to
castle. Yeah, I dunno. That's happened.
Go in there and Pedro Munoz is there in shorts. They're like,
what the fuck is going on? Like rematch. Rematch. Yeah.
Fuck yeah. That's a crazy, oh, I was saying the bed though, man.
I gotta pull out couch. Yeah. Why do you have a block
here from the pullout couch? The uh, yeah, I, so I, it'd be,
it'd be my house. I got my real estate license back in March.
I finally finished my, uh, I did like one flipped before in Arizona.
It didn't go so well, but I gained experience like,
let's use that as like the cost of doing business. So I learned a lot, man.
Learn a lot about like developing.
And you looked at yourself now we took the course together the same year.
How to flip houses.
There's actually a bus tour going on right now and I guy hit me up,
Nicole Manya he wants me to,
he wants me to come down [inaudible] probably tomorrow in Irvine.
But those guys, they kill it man. [inaudible] doing like crazy commercial stuff.
They're doing stuff in just residential Hawaii Quintas doing thousands,
right? Yeah. That's awesome for him. I got my license.
I haven't sold a single house yet since March that was traded for a fight,
you know, so it's gotta be hard. Yeah.
Well I don't even know how to use the fucking mos yet. So that's the problem.
So you asked me to show you something like send you houses like listings.
I should be able to like comprise like some data of like things that fit your
criteria and then send it to you on like an automatic email.
But I gotta learn how to do that. So kind of just sit in there.
But to get back to about saying I like I bought the house, um,
after the Cody statement fight before the Cody statement fight.
So I'm like shitting bricks.
I'm like trying to close that house was about to um,
the deal was about to fall through the day of closing. I was like,
get the fuck Outta here. You're going to close this deal one way or the other.
Even if I got to shell out extra money, I was shut out the extra money.
So I get the house next year. No, my mortgage is three grand.
So three grand plus my utilities, I'm looking at about like 35, 3,600.
Now when you equate like the salary that I make from fighting and everything in
New York taxes and all that, it's just not very, um, lucrative.
Yeah, it's not sustainable.
There's no way I could do it unless I'm fighting like three, four times a year.
Like guaranteed. If I'm not, I might be in some trouble.
I don't have health insurance right now. We all, yeah,
that's I and this is like crazy. That's crazy shit. That's crazy.
You're fighting in a cage without health insurance. Get hit by a car.
Just talking about your car today. If you get injured in a fight though,
you're compensated, right? I'm compensated. But if this is like an illness,
I'm not compensated for nothing like that. So it was a little different.
So that's why I'm like, yeah, I gotta I gotta make sure I like,
I don't get sick, I gotta make sure I'm doing the right things.
Look both ways before across the street, like little things like that. But uh,
yeah, so I bought the house, whatever I managed it managed to close.
So I'm trying to figure out ways to sustain this.
Cause then my mom's in a situation where she's like facing an eviction at the
time. Uh, she's going through a five year divorce now is going to be,
October is going to be five years. And uh, it's just my dad's, he's a fuck.
He could be a pain in the ass to deal with in terms of just using his rational
humanly side of thinking. He just doesn't get it. And, uh,
I've been trying to like somehow be like the, the, the bridge between the two.
Cause you know, it's been a lot of fucked up years,
like domestic abuse and shit like that.
So I grew up with a lot of that man and um, my dad,
and not to get off subject but that shit fucked me up in terms of like my
confidence like as a kid, I mean he would just call a stupid and,
and all these names for whatever reason.
And I felt like even till like dating in middle school and high school was tough
for me because yeah it was the good looking kid.
But at the same time it's like I didn't know how to hold a conversation cause I
was never taught, I was never taught by my dad how to do certain things and um,
that made me like very self conscious and like approaching females and stuff
like that. Like they didn't approach me with my friends,
didn't start the conversation, forget about it. If I see any chick that I liked,
I had a crush on him. Forget about my talking to her.
Even my girlfriend to this day, went to the same high school,
never talked to her, we never spoke. And I thought she was wanting the sexiest,
prettiest, most beautiful females out there in the whole high school.
And I didn't, I just never talked to her. I just always see her.
I was smiling like, yeah, I want to talk to you, but I can't.
I just can't do it. I just can't do it. But now we're dating whatever. But um,
yeah man. So I had to learn how to do a lot of that stuff on my own, but I'll,
yeah,
I'm trying to bridge the gap between the two of them and it's just been really
tough. So she's facing the eviction.
I got to figure something out now and I ended up, long story short,
I don't want to like go too crazy into details, but um, long story short,
I won the fight with Cody statements, so that was huge for me.
If I didn't win that fight,
I would have been fucked in terms of like really trying to help my mom cause I
wasn't trying to take my money,
my hard earned money and throw it into something like a rental. I'm like,
it just doesn't make any sense cause she doesn't have a green papers.
So she wasn't working. My Dad paid for everything. He was like,
he was a sugar daddy, you know, he fucking, you know,
he did his street pharmacy stuff.
He had his street pharmacy ways and so he made his money the way he made his
money, you know, and um, she never had to work. I mean,
she's an interesting way of putting it. It's treat pharmacy. I don't know,
like what's like, okay to say, you know,
before there's people knocking at the door. So yeah,
you're saying just confessed to like years and years and years of no,
no bandaids. Yeah.
But my mom would help them and I just felt obligated as a, as her,
one of her oldest kids.
I know she's got two kids older than me on her side alone. She has 10 kids.
Just with my mom, not with my dad, like just her alone and then with my dad,
she has eight.
I'm the oldest of the eight with my dad and then the two other kids are from
another two different guys.
So it's just our family trees like just fucking wacky.
It's just all over the place.
Like my family has even met my girlfriend's family. It's just like, it's, it's,
I don't even know how the wedding's going to go if we, you know,
we have to decide to get married. Like do I have, yeah.
Do I invite like who do I invite?
Who do I not invite to make sure there's no like, oh this is just a little,
we did it last minute. Guys ran off to Mexico and have a party though.
This way the wedding doesn't get ruined. Yes.
Then you have a party afterwards and then everybody goes sideways.
We had a great wedding. Yeah. You just go, you just,
you and her and maybe like a couple other people just go to fucking The Bahamas
or something. She, that's what I want to do. But push.
You see what she wants to do. She has a huge family too,
so she wants everybody there.
She's got family in California and Texas back in Salvador. I'm like, Yo,
it is.
It is that I'm probably going to be paying the entire bill for it isn't that
special day is so nuts.
You spend so much money like shouldn't we not spend this money and just go on
vacation? That's what, that's the way I live my life. And also more than that,
like you have a lot of weddings are like a fucking car. Yeah,
the costs like a brand new car.
It was a kid's tuition should feed your child's tuition that you're spending on
a wedding. You know, what are we doing with all this money? Society, man,
I think you see everyone it got they the way they dressed it up and they
programmed our brains to,
and if you kind of like stuck in your ways and that's what you want,
that's what you want and I get it. I want it to be,
everyone wants to be their princess moment. I get it. I get it. This is to me.
Yeah,
exactly. Very important to me. I'll do, mate. That's very important. Yeah,
I can imagine her listening to this right now. We're just joking. I'm sorry.
I probably look, I'm married too. Look, I should shut the fuck up. Yeah,
you want to be happy. This a that expression. Happy wife. Happy life.
Just whatever. What do I gotta do? I was just like my house.
I don't have a God damn thing on the walls of my house. I didn't,
I didn't put nothing up. It's all my wife deck.
That's why this place is so crazy. This she did this too.
This place is free. This is where my fucking house should look like.
B Elk Goals and American flags and Mitzi shore and Tie Buddhas. Richard Pryor.
That ghostbuster gun. That's what my fucking house. If you like this,
this podcast studio, but if you go over my house, you'd be like, oh,
we're in the wrong place. Joe Doesn't live here. That's funny.
This is like a a woman or a gay guy. Hey,
I hear you man. That's how my house is set. My, my girlfriend hasn't,
she doesn't, she hasn't moved in yet,
so she hasn't been able to like put her own special touches.
Ring her mattress and get the fuck over. Yeah. Yeah. Pretty much.
I need a fucking bed. I'm like, dude, we need new best site.
We were just going to take yours. I bet he's actually pretty comfortable,
but what about one of these,
maybe make a deal with this company that gave Jamie that bed.
What's that company again? Let's call it eight sleep. Go brother sleep. Listen,
reach out to me. Reach out to aljamain. That's make something.
Listen, if there's something that really does work like that,
I mean I need to try it. The chill pat is one that Marxists and recommends.
He said it's incredible. He said it's a game changer to cools your body down.
You sleep way better. I don't know if it's gonna hold my apnea,
but it might feel better while I'm sleeping.
The other thing that'll help you apnea is if you can get to a position where
you're got a pillow where your, your mouth is down, like falling forward. Yeah.
Like if you, if you can instead of sleeping on your back,
which is your tongue is going to fall back, sleep boy,
your mouth is kind turned forward. Cause if I forget my mouth,
so I go on the road, that's what I do and it's fine.
As long as I make sure that my head is pointing down,
it's like an awkward angle.
I wake up my next killing me and I got bad neck like from like voting disc and
herniated disc in my neck just from wrestling and orange Jujitsu.
So everybody does. Right. And yeah, it's fucked up.
Do you ever use one of those harnesses?
We hang from your neck a little bit until it's spinal decompression.
I think he's talking about one that, that, that sleep mask thing. Oh yeah.
I was like that too. You breathe out of your nose and it looks ridiculous.
I tried that. Everyone was laughing at me. I can't sleep, I can't go to bed,
you know. But if you breathe out of your nose cause does your nose work good?
Yeah, I think so. I don't think it's deviated. It might be, I don't know.
Can you go? Do you do a yoga class ever and just breathe out of the nose only?
Mm. I've done I think one yoga class and that was in college.
That was a long time ago. But if you can, um, these,
uh, neck things, if you can, you can find them on Amazon. They just,
a neck harness saw expensive straps to a door. The top of the door,
decompress, click, click, click.
You pull it and it pulls your neck and you can just relax and it just stretches
your neck out. What's it called? It's home. I mean, I might,
I know decompression harness. Yeah, I probably could get of those.
They'll help you.
I feel good to relax your neck when you do like the incline bed and you can hang
upside down. Even all the plug rushes to your head, which sucks. Yeah.
I have one of those too. Yeah. That's the only thing I don't like lower back.
Yeah. Thing right there. That's what I have no things that shit.
I gotta do that in a safe setting. My safe space. Yeah.
Quinoa was looking at me. Yeah. It's definitely that.
But you pull on it and it click, click, click, click, click, and it,
it relaxes your neck. What's the clicking? Is that the spine? It's like the ugh.
The lover. A little notches. Each notch. It like pulls it a certain amount.
Yeah, click click and you pull it more click, click.
And then when you want you just sit up and you release all the tension.
I just had a terrible thought in my head with that jerking off now cause that's
what like people die from. That's how David Carradine from Kung Fu, he died,
strangled himself, always beaten off. Allegedly might've got killed.
I heard he might get killed by the mob. Heard. Yeah. He um,
he died of what they call auto erotic x fixed creation.
Do you remember the band? [inaudible] not annex. NXS Yeah,
I was thinking of the car and the sex in excess. The lead singer, same thing.
He died from autoerotic fixation.
There's dudes who try to choke themselves where they beat off [inaudible]
pure
level shit was a preacher,
a preacher. They caught this preacher wearing a wet suit.
He had a dildo up his ass and he was choking himself and he blacked out while
he's beaten off and died. Ray Donovan. Yeah. Something like that might've been,
they might've set him up to, who knows? He might've been banging some kids.
That's all I got back at him. Yeah. Nah, I'd never heard of that. That's that's,
that's a different way of erotic association.
That's a different kind of a s it was what's called a SMS or yeah,
that mess is sadomasochistic. Right. That's sadomasochism and bonding. S,
m whatever the fuck it is. Bonded next level, man.
I can never get off on that. They say that something about being, being choked,
that it accentuates the orgasm so well, I mean, come on,
say Babe Ben.
Fucking ridiculous. Give me that look. You
know, you know strangle. Can we get that little lasso?
Stop roping cows and wrap it around your neck will give you a full report.
When I get back.
It's just Alabama minister who died in June of accidental mechanical fix you.
It was found hogtied wearing two complete wetsuits, including a face mask,
diving gloves and slippers, rubberized underwear.
And a head mask according to the autopsy report,
51 year old pastor Monica, what does it say?
Montgomery's cause death was not caused by foul play. If that is not foul play,
how do you play and can I read your rule book? Does this shit seems foul?
Yeah. He had a dildo
up his ass, right? Didn't he covered this bomb reason.
Kingdom covered deal though. Hey, you don't want to get pregnant, right?
Condom covered dildo up his ass while he was beaten up.
I mean that's,
that's from like trying to like hold back all your sin pretending that you don't
have any sin cause you're a pastor and it just bubbles up to the surface.
You would had to special order that too. It's illegal to sell those in Alabama.
Good legals to serve. What those? Yeah. Really?
Oh stop hating on dildos.
Oh just didn't have a Dildo in Alabama. I just heard to like,
I think Mississippi is the only state you're allowed to drink while you're
driving. As long as you don't cross over the 0.08 Gat is God damn hilarious.
Beer in your front seat. Wow. Mississippi.
Mississippi also has the fucking confederate flag. It's in, it's a state flag.
Yeah. Part of the state flag. It's like yikes. Wild laws down there.
The wild, wild west. Wild, wild south. I don't think
if I've ever been to Mississippi I have it. I don't know if I've ever been,
I haven't even been to New Orleans. I still want to go there.
New Orleans is wild to hear nothing but good things. Great people, man.
I can't wait. Nice friendly people and the food is outstanding. Yeah.
I got this idea that I've been trying to do for like years now and I haven't
been able to make this happen because of financial situations.
The whole thing like with my mom and shit like that,
like trying to get the house for and whatnot. Um, but I want to hit like every,
do like a cross country tour and hit every state,
every capitol and document the entire fucking thing.
Like a one two month like escapade or some shit.
Maybe after the next fight I would like to.
But then I'm also thinking like I would have some point like to maybe have kids
or something, but then I'm like,
if I have a kid and I can't leave her while she's pregnant and unless she just
comes along like, but then she works and she's in school. I'm like, damn,
does everything, just nothing ever works out unless I just go
workout. I feel bad. If I were to just leave for that long,
you got to win the title 10 I'm like, y'all, I'm out. Could we get that?
That's big. Scratch about like, come on. What would you do if you won the title?
Would you, would you vacate and just say enough?
What do you have an idea of when you want to stop fighting?
Oh, I see. You know, it was very interesting that you asked me that.
It's always been,
I got asked the guys at the gym too has always been a 30 to 32 so we're close.
I'm close.
Whether or not I'm gonna feel the same when I'm 32 being that I'm about to be 30
I'm realizing how close that is. If I, you know,
realize my dream and I got the real estate thing,
I got a college degree in physical education. I'm trying out for the FT and Y.
Um, I'm still unsure how that's gonna work out.
It's just the flexibility of the schedule and actually being able to have
healthcare benefits for myself and my family. Whoever that is. You know,
talk to Steve Pay. Um, no, but I have firefighter friends back home. I know.
I actually, I think I have one time and he told me he love it. Uh,
Eddie Island too, right? Yeah. Eddie won
that as well. Yeah, they fight.
I think I was talking to him about that briefly in Chicago.
Shout out to the mustache Mafia. Yeah, he gave me one of those things. Yeah.
I don't even know he was fighting on the car until I seen it pop up and I'm
like, Holy Shit. And then you know, he had a crazy ass fight. That car crazy.
Then you guys, yeah, wild. It's a wild fight, man. Eddie Weiland's a tank.
He's one of the more unusual fighters when you watch him move.
Like he's one of those guys where you could see him in a silhouette. You Go,
oh that's Eddie Wineland. Yeah. Cause shades and everything. Crazy, crazy,
like weird style to try to sort out. Like he's,
he's so unusual in his movement. First WEC champion, right? Yes. Yes.
Way Back in the day. That's show.
That's back when it was in northern California, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Where was that? The little cage? Yeah.
It was like where the fuck was the original original WEC was like,
I don't want to say Lodi, but, well I don't think it was low Dodd,
but it was like some more look more California or something like that.
Well those weird spots.
Yeah. I, I never looked at the location.
Like now I start to pay attention to things like that now.
Like more like where I fall,
where the fight is going to be held and things like that.
Cause I always end up going to the events from time to time.
It is Lamar WBC 20 with Sony. One was in La Moore, California. Yeah.
That's where they used to have them out there.
That's when Reed was running at Rio Reed Harris. Yeah. I love that dude.
He's a good dude. He's a great dude. Yeah. Yeah. I mean those,
those pioneers of the game man, those guys who, you know,
like Bud Brotzmann used to run king of the cage and these people that run these
little small organizations where everything started. Yeah.
When we used to do it in California, um, when um,
the first started doing MMA shows in California,
they had to do 'em on native American reservations cause you couldn't have it
anywhere. It wasn't sanctioned in California.
So like when we would go to see king of the cage and Eddie Bravo used to work
for king of the cage and I would go with him out to these events.
We would have to go to the middle of nowhere. Man. These weird ass casinos.
That's the only place we could go to see the fights. Yeah.
I formed my reservation couple of times in New York cause we couldn't find it in
New York. Yeah.
I still came in fight in New York because I got some like medical thing. They,
they're not sure if I was born with it or not,
but I didn't even know about it until I got my, my had my UFC debut in Vegas,
UFC one 70 and um, yeah, I had to get a cat scan,
got the cat scan and I had like two spots on my brain,
so they just kept monitoring it and I had to go see a neurologist and all that
and they just want to make sure it wasn't going like bleeding out and I wasn't
gonna like just die in the octagon randomly. And um, you know,
so they were looking out for me,
but I've been able to fight everywhere except for New York and I'm just hoping
that these guys do the right thing so I can at least fight one time before my
careers or southern all sudden and done in my home state.
I think that would be something that I've dreamed up for like a very long time.
You know,
I never knew this would have happened until my debut and kind of just do a
wrench into everything. Do the, the neurologist, it's okay.
Yeah. Um, clarify. It's just the wording in the,
in the New York bodies sanctioning rule, whatever. And I'm like,
so what do you guys have to do to change it? I'll just,
I think they say just a doctor has to go like rewrite it or some shit like that.
I'm like, but why does this taking so long? It's been years now. I've been like,
just every time I see Kim, Hey Kim,
hey is the doctor gonna go like change the rule or something so I can fight in
New York and uh, nothing, you know, I don't know. They're not,
I guess the not moving the needle from me. So that sucks. I guess New York,
they're probably don't want to take any chances because it's so recent that they
even got it approved, right? Yeah. Something that's like years, right.
How many years? Three now.
2016 2016 I was there for the bill when they signed it. Yeah,
that was a fun time. Those fucking Madison Square Garden Cards are bananas.
Yeah. They always put bananas cards on MSG. Yeah,
I was there live for the condom. McGregor, Eddie Alvarez. Oh,
just the Wayne's were electrifying. I was like, Yo man,
chills sells me out that building. Yeah. Me,
you think about all the amazing boxing fights that happened in that building.
I mean that is the most famous arena and all of combat sports.
Madison fucking square garden.
I remember the first time I walked in there for the UFC, I got chills.
I was like, I can't believe we're here right here. I get chills.
I'm getting goosebumps right now. Just thinking about it.
Like you walk in that place, it has a special feeling man. Yeah.
And I just hope to God I could get to feel that one day at least one day.
Come on New York. I hope I'm on.
So right now you're dealing with a, a bit of a thumb injury, right? You have a,
this cast that you have on your arm right now is, um,
this is to isolate your ligament. Yeah. So in the fight,
I don't know at what point where one of the punches I threw,
I guess I landed with the thumb cause the UFC gloves,
they don't protect the thumb. There's no padding on the thumb.
I don't know if I like it or don't like it, but whatever.
It had been fighting like that with these guys for so long. Now at this point,
I don't really even notice it. Just the first time I really,
really banged up my hand, but it's like the, uh,
the ligament on the radio and the owner side that hold the thumb to keep it from
like turning out like my thumb on this side. They,
they compared it and he saw how lax, it wasn't this side. He was like, dude,
is it, does this hurt? I was like, Nah, that's just normal. That's my thumb.
So they think my thumb being able to do that on the other side.
Maybe it's just my anatomy. Do it again. But um, yeah, it's like,
it's kind of freaky. Yeah. Button locks. Oh my God. Yeah.
But does it hurt it like 15 degrees more movement,
but I'm double jointed in my tums, so I don't know if that's what it is.
That looks like it hurts. I got a tap right here.
Did you see Craig Jones and Anthony Rumble Johnson? Had a grappling match I saw,
but I didn't get to, I didn't get to catch a match. Try Google,
go to Craig Jones Instagram. He wrapped him up quick rumble,
took him down and Craig Jones got ahold of that leg and was, it's gorgeous.
It's a beautiful transition. If you're a fan of leg locks, it's just scary.
And Jones who was a rumble, Johnson's obviously a gigantic man.
He's in like, he's like two 60 now and Craig Jones is probably about two 10,
but when they rolled, but there's a video of it on a Craig's um,
Instagram if you find it. Yeah, it's right. Um, that,
that's probably it. Try it right there versus Goliath. Yeah.
Kai Jones versus your life. Is this it? Let me see it.
It's a repost he put out. Here's the damn for you. Okay.
Make it like a little larger presented by [inaudible] sun in submission
underground. This seems like just to advertise on
Ortho Oreo. You're right now. Is it just to advertise? I sent it to him.
I sent him a congratulations in a, a set date. Well, maybe, maybe,
maybe it's not on his, maybe it's something, let me find that real quick.
Cause we could, we could do that. Imagine about the fight.
So when that big and the big guys like I'm gonna fuck you up.
And then all the guys just like, I'm going to break your fucking ankles.
It's like damn, that's a, yeah.
And then he goes out there and he actually does it, you know? No, it says here,
I'll send it to you Jamie. Hold on a second. Yeah, hang on a second. Two,
two, two. Correct. All right, Joe,
I sent it to you.
Um,
do you get on the Instagram? It's actually from Craig Jones BJJ.
From his Instagram. Yeah. I don't know. Well it wasn't showing.
Yeah, it wasn't showing me. Here it is.
So watch this. So rumbles on top and Craig elevates with that, right.
Passing passes on. Boom. Locks the hole gets the heel hook. Tap. But he,
he even fight the hands. Did not bite the hands.
He didn't even rap the whole of the heel. Yeah. They were still in transition.
He had the legs like laced up. He had inside control. You see this watch,
he gets it, flips, rolls it. He's got the leg and rumbles like, I get it.
Fuck that. Fuck that. I'm walking out of here. Exactly. He's like, alright,
well now I know I walked in here and I'm walking out.
That's the more amazing thing about leg locks is smaller people can get away
with things from the bottom that it's very difficult to get away with because
you're using both of your legs to control a person's leg.
It's like you have so much strength in the leg locks and so much control with
those two legs around one leg.
I mean you are obviously one from the [inaudible] team,
which is that that is the where it all started with John Don her with Dean
listers, so the dawn,
her and dawn her refined that system and Eddie Cummings and and all these
fucking animals that are coming out of there now.
There's so many leg lock specialists out of that part of the gym or that part of
the world like that one gym. That Hens, Oh,
Gracie gym is responsible for a gigantic evolution in,
in leg locking. Yeah. Those guys are phenomenal to work with.
Whenever I could get down here to get some training and it's always fun.
It's always a battle that Nicky Ryan kids, super young, still grind. Gary, Tony,
Gary, tone in leg lock machines. Yeah. Damien, Jason Raod, nick, Nick,
nick, those guys
or those guys are animals. Saturday's scary ripping knees apart,
but you know, they say, why would you ignore 50% of the human body?
Like why would you want 50% of the human body?
He's such a weird guy to talk to. He's tardy. He's Xavier.
Donna is too smart. He is.
He makes me feel like a shit like [inaudible] nothing done.
What do you do from here? I'm like, what dude?
Don't tell me you're making me nervous, man. Say nothing wrong.
He was making fun of the whole, you have a 10th planet black belt. Come on man.
Just tell me what to do. Don't mock me. I'm here though. Oh,
I want to know. I want to learn. John. This is a judge free zone. Damn it.
But he's so smart
in his analysis of positions instead of just rolling and getting better and
drilling and comparing,
he's done just like a systematic analysis of various positions.
What you need to do, what you need to master, where are you going from here?
And I, I, from what I understand from everybody,
Eddie Commons is a big part of that as well. Let him out. Yeah.
Eddie coming some master. He's a master, just so good at leg logs.
So I've watched that guy compete multiple, multiple times online.
It's just like, well his transitions are so smooth. It's like it's a,
it's amazing. Yeah. I think I saw him competed the uh,
Eddie Bravo's invitational to it. Ebi.
Pretty sure I was there for him like that. Um, that rule set is a,
an interesting rule set and I think that's the best rule set for. Like,
if you get a stalemate at the end of, you know, initial time period,
then from there you have a chance to, uh,
you go at it for a certain amount of times til someone gets tapped and you start
out in different positions.
You started either for with back control or what you call spiderweb or you like
have your own side control,
your legs are crossed the face and you have the arm trapped inside but you don't
have an arm bar fully extended and you're like ready go.
Can you start from there?
And then they calculate how long it takes to escape versus whether or not
somebody tapped. So if you tap somebody,
they have a chance to tap you and they have a chance to get back in that same
position. But if you tap them quicker than they tap you, then you win.
Yeah, it's great. It's great.
The only position of that I just really didn't like that much was uh,
the back control position.
Cause you see a lot of the times the guys will escape and let the guy ended up
in Mt. And then that would be considered an escape. But it's like,
but was there really an escape? If you're in a fist fight,
do you really want to be there? That position melted. You didn't escape Shit.
[inaudible] get fucked up. It's cool. It's a good point. Like right.
You should have to escape. Escape. Yeah.
Or You should have to get out of mountain. But did you, that's what I'm saying.
It's like when you think about it and the concept, like are you,
are we training guys to set them out?
Right. Is that what happens?
So I'm not 100% sure on this Geo Martinez Geo,
who's a beast. He's one of Eddie's black belts,
actually caught Cummings in an armbar.
He's one of the few guys that have ever seen tap Eddie. Yeah.
And this was from spiderweb. But you notice when he goes to spiderweb,
he controls that right leg. Yep. That's a very, I noticed that. It's very,
very important that a bridging. Yeah. What's also you, you just,
you could keep control of one part of the body.
So there's no movement side to side, right? Yes.
He's not moving around towards the head. He stuck in that spot.
So whether or not he extends or doesn't extend, you know,
whether any catches the arm there, I mean, you could still defend.
It's possible, but it cuts out a lot of the pathways.
He creates a lot of control. There's no rocking. Yeah, exactly.
Like even here, even here, he still got that leg, he's still got that leg.
And you're always in a bad spot with a guy like Chico who's a,
he's an arm bought while he's at just a Jujitsu master.
But what wait is this bomb ass 45, I think it's 45, I believe.
And Geo, like his brother Richie [inaudible],
they started out as a break dancers.
So these guys are strong as fuck. They're crazy physical dexterity.
They could do all kinds of nutty shit with their bodies.
Now he's got the near side leg. I'm just going back to the far. Yeah. And uh,
this is a bad fight to showcase Eddie Cummings cause you want him getting
caught. But he got caught here because they started off from spiderweb.
You know, he's not starting out from a, from a neutral position.
They're starting out from a disadvantage.
And this is one of the rare times he's,
so he's got the arm and that spiderweb and now he's got like a figure for what
he had to think for us, like a little loose now. But he was, yeah,
it's really loose. It's called the arm crush. Yeah,
he was going for like a biceps. Okay.
And then it really is almost snaps your forearm. No socks. Tremendous.
Tremendous pressure on the forum. It's awful. Especially wouldn't go big guys.
Yeah, but it could be a bicep slicer as well that uh,
those positions are terabytes up. Just a crushing of the limb like that.
It's a terrible feeling, but he eventually catches him here. Dude,
your arm is so shot after getting out of that.
I know you don't want so compressed, you know,
it's a horrible feeling too.
It's like forearms and you're legging in the leg.
The back of the calf is crushing it and the other leg is squeezing down like a
triangle. It's, oh, it's awful. Jujitsu's amazing man. It really was amazing.
Amazing martial art. I would probably forever do it to him.
Like my late forties, 50s songs. I'm like still able body and all that.
You know, if you find good training partners,
you can do it as long as the thing about the human body is like,
you only got so many explosions in you. You know,
so many times you could push a guy off you so many times you could die forward
so many times you could just thrust up from the bottom.
But if you do things with the right technique, like John Jackman Shadow,
I think he's at least 50 John jocks still rolls and you don't have any injuries.
You still roll. But he's,
you'd never see John Jock just like he never goons at anything.
A guy can goon at us. I've gooned out of things before.
If somebody catches you to stop me just fucking raw, I just explode. And,
and you catch them when they're
maybe resting a little bit and you'd goon out of it never goes out.
Smooth and technique. It's all defense. It's perfect. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's just flow. It's not like, oh yeah.
Well that was what's interesting about watching Michael Kia San Diego Sanchez.
Like he flowed, it just flowed. There was no, like,
he didn't have to do anything crazy. He was in control.
Like from the moment he clenched him, got ahold of 'em. He's just moving,
constantly changing, you know, changing control, submission attempts,
control submission attempts. It was just beautiful. Yeah. Yeah. I,
I got to rewash that fight. I was at a wedding when I was watching those fights.
Ah. I was like partially when my dancing shoes,
cause I didn't want to be like disrespectful.
So we got the fights up and we're like hovering over the table. Oh,
speaking of which shit, I told Eve Edwards,
we would watch that shit while it's on in the background. Oh, turn the TV on it.
Put It on ESPN too though. If it's on ESPN two or is it on 'em?
Eventually it goes to ESPN plus. Let's see if it's on ESPN two right now.
He'd say, okay. Word to your mother and other motherfuckers.
Doug Jitsu. I told them we should watch it. I love that dude.
I'm glad he's making his way into transitioning into a commentary too.
He's excellent. Really good.
Well you're so such a technical fighter that uh,
he's a really good at transitioning into, uh, what's happening with the tone,
by the way. Just, I forgot we didn't, I never finished my, um, bed stories.
Well, not even the bed like so let's go back real quick and just to finish it,
cause I, people are probably gonna ask me like what ever happened with your mom.
And so, so after, after the Cody stamen fight,
I needed to, I needed to win that fight.
Otherwise I would have been in a really bad spot because of all the renovations
I did t to my house cause my house smell like cigarettes. It was like,
it was really fucked up.
But I got in a short sale in a really nice neighborhood and a mass pico I'm in,
I'm in the hood, the hood of Mass Pico now. It's not the hood,
it's really people. That's really nice. It's really nice.
It is nice to have a lawn. Um, yeah.
So that's nice that you get the short sale like some other ones.
Folly and fuck up. Yeah.
I can sneak in and take a nice house in the same suspectful literally play.
Oh Bet they were there. They were kind of happy to get rid of it to be honest.
I think they were struggling with the payments or whatnot. So it was cool.
But I loved my neighborhood. I don't have real neighbors.
I have side yard so I'm not in anyone's way but to to make ends meet.
I airbnb my house so I sleep in a basement.
So that's why I had to pull out cuts cause I didn't want to make it all packed
up.
I mean like you know like the little cricket guys that'd be jumping around all
over the place.
I didn't want like a ton of shit for them to hide and start like making a little
cricket babies. So,
so I just got the pull out couch. It's like easy to clean and got a rug.
Whatever crickets in your house are so fucking annoying.
If you can't find them, they're the worse. They are the fucking word.
I will find you. I and I will,
but I don't kill crickets when you at the time,
most of the time I grabbed when I throw him outside,
I don't know why I grabbed with your hand prejudice against certain bugs.
If I find a spider, it's dead. Dead. You're dead. But if I find a cricket,
I'm like, ah, little fella. Come on, let me get you. They don't bite her.
They bite your hands. No
cricket. Just trust me bro. I'm just trying to get you outside.
I'm trying not to kill you. Yes. I get the little traps,
the sticky traps and I feel so bad because they just wither away and I'm like,
it's such a fucked up way to go. But I'm like, you came into my hood,
you came into my territory. This is my land. That's right. You know.
So snakes in my yard dead. All of them. They have snakes. Yup. Rattlesnakes,
rattlesnakes, dead, dead. All of them. People say you shouldn't kill it.
Shut the fuck up. I have kids. Never had a yard yard here,
man. Yeah. Out here in California for sure. Rattlesnakes are everywhere.
I went to look at a house and um, I stomped a rattlesnake to death in the,
in the front yard of the House of this House that we were looking at poisonous.
Yes. There was a fucking rattlesnake sitting there in the front yard. And uh,
I just, I just saw it. I said, okay, I'm just gonna let's just go.
This is what I would do if I lived here. I'm gonna stomp this mother fucker.
I knew I was in there not that fast. Okay.
That they're fast when they strike.
But if a rattlesnake is flattened out and he can't see you,
he doesn't see you coming out. Stomped that motherfucker.
I just crushed his head. Dumped him. That's bad ass.
Cause I would not fuck with that thing. I'm like, oh I didn't, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't if it was like pulling back. I was like,
but I saw where it was and like these people live in this house that they were
selling and I was like, they don't want this fucking thing here.
No one wants a rattlesnake there. Fucking yard shit man. It's just fucking,
I would've been scared shitless man. I'm like,
I'm going to sound called the exterminator.
Well I developed a real anger for them when they bit my dogs.
I've had three times I've had to take my dogs to a,
the veterinarian with their face all swollen up like a water balloons grown out
of the cyber head.
Cause I got bit rattlesnakes are fucked up too because what their venom does is
it digest your tissue. It's one of the,
it's something about their venom is how it helps them like eat rabbits and
things that they kill. Cause the,
the venom not only does it kill you but it kinda breaks down your tissue. Yeah.
So when, when people get bitten by it, it's real bad man.
They have to get these horrible skin grafts and they get necrosis where all the
tissue around where the bite was all dies off.
So like sometimes you could see the bone [inaudible] bone. Yeah.
Not for the weak heart.
That's why stop it still those motherfuckers out you guys to go fuck you sound
like me or you. Yeah. And I see,
I'm not big into like the Wilderness surprisingly cause my parents are from
Jamaica. So you know, we have like that Caribbean upbringing.
We weren't like raised in a traditional American home, like the lifestyle.
So we have a different like rules and everything and uh,
we never really experienced like that type of stuff in like Jamaica and shit
like that.
What's going on, Jamie?
Oh one I can't figure out why the DIRECTV is not coming through the TV,
but two it doesn't even start for another 25 minutes, so, oh, okay.
Starts at five 30 all right,
well we'll check it out in five minutes or 25 minutes.
Is it start on ESPN plus in 25 I was just, I was looking for ESPN plus.
It's not on there. It says ESPN two at five 30 I don't know. Oh fuck.
I'm sure must be the previews though or the prelims.
Maybe there's prelims I would think, but it's not. Oh, here we go. Well,
I liked it. The PFL is doing what they're doing. Well go,
but just go up to the machine and see if he could your remote control with him
plus won't work on that TV. I'd have to get it through my laptop.
It will will be IEPs. ESPN plus at five 30 no, ESPN Tuesday at five 30 right.
This is that probably had to be done with him and we were trying to explain it
so it should be on ESPN plus right now I'm trying to get it on there and then
ESPN too. Right, which would be on the TV, but I can't even get,
I don't know why Directv is not working on it. We'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out. Eve Edwards shout out.
I like the fact that doing that though, the PFL is given away all that money.
I love it. I love it. Six or eight people each year.
Was it six or I think it was 60 cents on the show. Put a $1 million.
If you win the season, that's amazing. More money.
I think there's more money that I've made in 13 UFC fighter
thinking about jumping ship. Uh, Nah, go. You know what it is.
I would need to, before I would ever do that, I would want to win the belt.
And I think that is a very obtainable and realistic thing for me to, to,
to be able to realize, um, that dream before I would ever jump ship.
Because it's almost like what mighty mouse did. He was like,
okay with leaving because he was a UFC champs, super dominant.
He didn't really lose that, say unify in my eyes.
I don't think he lost that fight. I think at worse,
at best it was a draw on all. I don't think there was any real clear cut loser,
but I didn't think so. Udall one, I didn't think mighty mouse loss, but uh,
for him to go to another organization and if he does win the belt,
it's like arguably like you really can't deny the guys one of the goats if not
the ego, you know? So that's the way I kind of look at it.
And I'd probably be retired anyway cause 32 is close to this class now.
You can't deny him anyway. I mean, no matter what happens from here on out,
Martin Mouse in my opinion technically is the best ever. The best ever.
Technically.
The thing about him versus John Jones in my eyes that John has faced different
competition. Yeah. I think John just fought more dangerous guys.
And also John is completely undefeated.
The only has that one loss to Matt Hamill,
which is a disqualification in a fight where he was totally dominant in what,
I think it was a bad call anyway.
Yeah. I thought Matt was fucking them up, man.
You can keep that shit up. I was like,
it was my memory completely shot. Fuck no,
but did I look at it like this? See now that mouse is removed
and there's new life at the flyweight division.
Everything is super competitive now. Right? So it goes to show,
maybe it speaks volume on just how good my emails just really is compared to
everybody else. Maybe that's why the division just looked like that.
And people are like, oh, you're just a little guys.
Not like fighting the big guys. I get that.
But it's like the same thing with Jon Jones,
but now there's like closer competition.
Now you see John Jones going into decisions a lot more as opposed to finishing
the older veterans. Who were the pioneers? Who were the, uh, the Shogun?
Who is the rampage? Jackson's the,
who else has he murdered that? Um, Maddy, you're saying?
I mean he wasn't a champ, but um, Vito Belfort, like those guys,
even though veto almost snapped that arm in half, that was crazy.
Fucking insane. I jumped out of my fucking, I
showed you what an animal John Is. He didn't tap,
just let his arm get fucking jacked and then wound up tap and v tore the next
round. Yeah. John is, he's not just talented.
His mind is just unstoppable. He's just got incredible.
His ability to overcome adversities,
ability to get out of bad situations. The ability to press on.
We saw that in the Gustafson find me. He wasn't in shape for that fight at all.
He, they said he was barely training. Well ice. I've partied with John,
not like the hardcore party that he does that he has done.
Let me say he has done, I'm not sure if party,
I'm not sure if he's still parties like that,
but when he was partying I would see him at the bar in Ithaca or he'll come out
to Courtland college cause Ethica was right down the road.
This was like when he was kinda going back and forth between Jackson's and our
gym. Um,
when I was upstate at bomb squad right before he like officially left and then
he was just coming home and going back to Jackson and coming home,
going back to Jackson's and it'd be like a couple of weeks before he's fighting,
this guy would be out there shots and he'll be like asking me if I want a drink.
I'm like, Yo Dude, I'm fighting like full like four weeks. I can't,
I can't do that. I have to, I have a hard time cutting weight for him.
I was like, dude, you don't like, you don't,
it's not hard for you to cut if you get fucked up like this.
I didn't mean I didn't ask him that, but I was like, I told him like, no,
I've got a fight coming up. I'm like, but I know you got to fight criminal.
But clearly it does not fucking matter cause you're John Jones,
you just going out there tooling people. Anyway,
I'll find it was what he said to Daniel Cormier,
I've beat you when I was on cocaine.
Cocaine is a hell of a drug. So it's a crazy thing to say to someone,
I beat you. And I did cocaine. Yeah, that says laughing.
That says a lot though, man does DC's a fucking animal, you know?
So it was like, this is just John Jones DC and then everybody else, you know,
he's that good man. But I'll tell you what man,
that Tiago Santos is a mother fucker. He kicked the shit out of John's legs,
put 'em in real danger. And you know,
I think John would've made a way easier fight if he decided to take him to the
ground, but he never did. Yeah,
she and I talked about that fight on my podcast this morning.
I do it on Wednesday. Everybody, what your podcast is where they get it. Oh,
the weekly scraps. You can get it on iTunes. Spotify,
Google play tune in and my website, me store on that cup.
I'll a bag young you. So what'd you say? But I was,
see the way I broke that fight down,
I was like John was always the guy that the aggressive pushing forward,
walking him down, cutting him against, cutting them,
cutting him off and pushing him back towards the cage.
And then Tiago looked like he was just kind of waiting and waiting to pounce.
Like he was looking for John to take a half step where he could time it while he
was off balance and try to rush him in blitz.
And with those big bungalows he was doing as a rampage,
Jackson calls him so I didn't feel like he connected or anything significant
besides the leg kick early in the first round where it kicked his leg.
I was like, all right,
this fight is going to be interesting cause he's attacking the legs early.
But then he started attacking the legs more.
But I felt like some of it wasn't really like,
it didn't seem like it was really affecting John the way people like watching it
live.
I thought it was landing a lot more and then when I rewatched it I was like,
I don't know.
I have to really like I'm looking at it and I put it in Slowmo and I'm watching
the fight. I'm like, well at that punched it in, connect that punched it,
connect to,
and then he did the one head kick that John got his hand up at the very last
second and was able to block it.
The one Dana White posted like a pitch on Instagram. Um,
was saying how tough he was fighting on the torn ACL,
the PCO and [inaudible] and MCL and meniscus. His fucking knees gone.
What was that, the first or second round? Was that six round? First round.
[inaudible] round. It might've been a second,
but did kick and we noticed his knee buckle. Yeah. Okay. And um,
I was the first round was the first one, so I was fractured shit. Yeah,
for Shit. Alright. Fuck. Oh, well that was one thing too.
When he buckled and he threw up, he was still thrown that mother fucker crazy.
Like Tibia Tibia. Yeah. Yeah. That's what I, that's hardcore. Yeah.
That's the big one. That's the big shinbone not the smaller one. The Fibula.
Oh yeah, they'll the CC's of blood. I sold them drainage shit.
They're pulling out a quarter of milk out of his fucking me who look at it and
they've already got a bunch in that little bucket. Yeah. Dr. Sanders did that,
right? Holy Shit Man. From the UFC. Yeah.
I think it was him who did that operation.
Ah, ouch.
Oh my God. Yeah. That knee is mangled.
So he had to immediately go into surgery after that. Yeah.
His knee was mangled and pastored, but I, tough guy. Yeah.
I just felt like John was still controlling, dictating like the control,
like the walls. Like it looked like there was moments where it's like, oh, ah,
but he didn't really hit them well.
He definitely kicked the shit out of his legs.
John had to be carried out in a wheelchair and landed some shots to the head
with punches. But John moved with them. Yeah, like rolling a little.
He rolled with them. He kept his hands up. He got caught, but he moved back.
He's still good at that back.
He's amazing at it and he's the best ever at controlling distance. He does.
The finger at the finger range pokies the pokey rate but a hit your left foot.
But he's so good at that. It's really about [inaudible].
I'm like, dude, no one's going to get past those long fucking
go go gadget inspector arms. You know what I mean?
But it's dangerous when the eyes get in them cause they have ha and it happened
to a bunch. Why don't you guys, he's he's, he's claimed,
you know how they have run a Razzie collecting arms on the shelf?
Like they did those pitches. John's got like eyeballs from every single,
oh this thing is
the whole light heavyweight division is in a strange state right now because
it's like you got John Jones and then who else?
You know you got Johnny Walker who wa who looked fantastic when he knocked out
meat shirts or cone off. But then he fell down and fucking Silva,
his shoulders still fucked up man. This,
they've showed him doing rehab like real recently on his Instagram page and I'm
like, whoa. This was like six months later, if that's all he can lift.
Like that's like stabilizer muscles and the stuff that's around the shoulder.
That shoulder might be, fuck you did just show that I did my shoulder, my labor,
yeah.
I've had all a bunch of a stem cell shot into my shoulder that healed it up,
but I had some pretty significant shoulder injuries. You did,
you did the Labor on surgery. Rotator cuff, no surgery.
I put out a full length rotator cuff tear and they used exosomes and it was
gone. The next MRI I had, the tear was gone. Just it goes,
it just seals up.
They did exosomes with platelet rich plasma and they mix it together and shoot
it into the injury and I went through the Rehab and then I got another Mr MRI
like six months later, eight months later, whatever it was.
When it started feeling good, they said, well, let's take a look at it,
and they were like, Holy Shit.
Like Dr Roddy McGee from Vegas who does a lot of the UFC stuff. He goes,
do you know how crazy that is? He's like, your tear is gone.
Doesn't exist anymore. That's, I got to see that.
It's like fucking next level shit.
Why don't they offer that to us when we have fucked up injuries?
I'm like my neck, my back, like I'm going to help you. Well,
I mean if they really think that you need it and they,
I don't know if they know that you have this injury,
like maybe you have to ask for it. I bet.
I feel like if you were one of your top guys,
you would want us to be back healthy, best as we can possibly be.
Prohibitively expensive for the UFC either if you, uh,
talked to Dr. Davidson or uh, talk to Don.
I mean I'll connect you with Dr. McGee and no,
they were my good shows with McGee. Yeah, he's got the good shit. Please.
Dr Roddy McGee in Vegas is always at the cutting edge. That guy is like,
every time I talked to him, he, there's some new thing that's going on.
There's new stuff now called Wharton's jelly that is even more powerful than any
of the, the previous stem cell ones.
And I had that shit shot into my shoulder too. And that's all in the states.
All in the states. Yeah.
Cause stuff in the states now is way more potent than it was just five years
ago. Okay. Because I have way more.
You had a guest on and they were talking about going to Dr Neil Riordan. Yeah.
Panama, Panama. Dang, they're on another level down a panel.
I sent my mom down there. Yeah.
My mom has a pretty bad knee and it sent it down to and it helped it.
But she's going to go down again. It's a, it's a heavy shit man. They can,
they do ivy stem cells too. They do a gang shit down there.
So. So let me ask you, so what exactly does it help?
Does it help with like regenerate soft tissue?
So like would that be like a tendon or ligament? Tendons, ligaments,
muscle injuries, things along those lines. They can regenerate ligaments,
regenerate tissue tears, you know,
like a [inaudible] stuff where you ordinarily would have to get things sewn up.
Like here's a perfect example. My friend John, his wife had a labor room tear,
so she had a tear in the Labor move her hip and the doctor was saying like,
most likely we're going to have to fix this. It's going to be a big deal.
It's going to be like months off your feet, like you have to,
you can't put any weight on it for I think like six to eight weeks or something
like that. Well,
she got exosomes shot in there and then when they went in for the second MRI,
there's nothing, no injury to freaky freaky.
So she had a little bit of a deformity in the bone of her hip that was causing
an irritation against the labor room.
They sanded down that part of the hip that was kind of bothering her. They,
they like cut away the part of the bone that's uh,
intruding on the labor them so that it clears the path.
And so it's not that invasive a surgery.
And then six weeks later she's good to go.
I mean she's rehabbing and everything and she'd still like,
they still had to cut her open a little bit,
but the big one was the labor and tear and all that was fixed.
So I had a bicep tendon repair. Now my bicep rolled up.
I don't know if you see Matt. Sarah's arm is like rolled up.
He never got his face. He never got it done.
He just took the fight and whatever. Um,
and I was contemplating doing the same thing as after I lost like Brian Caraway.
That was like the most devastating time in my life. That was like, uh,
I went off the fucking rails, but I gonna go off the road. That's another story.
I was just binge drinking. I was just out partying nonstop.
But my girlfriend,
I went through a pretty bad breakup at the point too and it was like,
it was two fights in a row. We got into fights. It was, I beat Johnny Eduardo.
We got into a fight at the hotel and he got bad,
like real bad to the point where like my brother seen it like she got,
she has a nice, she has a good right hook. Let's just say
to the back of My skull, Dad got physical, they got physical and Zack.
But isn't that unfair?
It's super unfair because she knows that you can't do it back. Yeah.
But she knows how I kind of grew, not kindness.
She knows how I grew up and it's good thing. My one of my brothers were there,
Troy. Um, he fights all cs pro. Um, I just, he's,
that's another story. He's actually a pretty good rapper, but, uh,
I think that's more of his call. And then fighting in my personal opinion, um,
he's more dedicated, would just, I would just say that, uh, so he saw it,
but he s I remember I would tell him stuff like, Nah, man, sometimes he's gone.
I was crazy, but I think that's all females, whatever. But, uh, he was like,
dude, if I had never, if I wasn't in the room to see that,
I would never had believes you that she would ever do anything like that.
I'm like, no you don't.
I'm not fucking lying on my fucking crazy for my Phyllis shit.
But it was like I had one girl swinging at me ever. Yeah. I couldn't believe it.
As she was swinging at me, I was like, oh, cut, but right hook, right hook.
I said, I don't believe this is happening.
It was real telegraph had zero training.
I just ducked on it. I was like, I can't even believe this.
I had duck under it and just get ahold of him. Like, what are you doing? Yeah,
it's, it's, it's, I covered up cause I didn't want to fight anyone argue.
I'm like, y'all just came with the biggest,
when I finished Johnny had the water. I was like, it was a boring fight.
But I got the finish is when I did the light that the cavitating hang thing and
then I started doing the Milly rock or whatever on any block.
So I was on cloud nine, you know,
I'm like celebrating and the way the fight started,
she kinda like she got more drunk than me at my own after party and I was,
I was like Yo pay,
I'm not in the mood to be holding your hair tonight in the toilet cause it's
mine. It's my night and I get it. You,
you're happy for me but let me be more happy than you like be like,
let me let me be the one really, really enjoying this moment.
And I just told my baby slow down. Like can you drink a little water?
And that turned into it just spiraled out of control.
You don't think I know how to Trey when it got crazy, hey got crazy.
But then a long story short, she right hook, right hook, left hook,
one of those hands. I think her hand is still fucked up from,
from my fight till this till this day. Till this day to this day.
He puts that Hashtag on his posts everyday.
It's the greatest fucking thing today. It's great hashtag show people too,
especially since to flatlines everybody to this day. But then,
then the next fight, caraway, another big fight. And we were still like shaky,
you know, get into arguments a lot. And I think we were kind of like,
I was like six years in at this point, no, like five years and sold it.
We're still figuring things out, you know,
we're young figuring things out and I'm still like enjoying the, the,
the fruits of my labor. Like I'm on top of the world right now.
I'm ranked fourth in the world about to have the biggest fight against Brian
Caraway, um, potential title implications on the line. And, uh, I'm, you know,
I did a lot of dumb stuff, you know, I was like talking to other people. I was,
I'm a very flirtatious guy, but I don't, I try not to cross the line, you know,
and sometimes, sometimes he's just something, whatever.
Sometimes you cross the line a by accident. It's not like an intentional thing,
you know, I love her or whatever. And, um, but then after that fight,
I lost my first loss. And you know, I, I cried in the fucking,
the half my after-party. I was at drays. All my boys and families were there,
my, some of my sponsors. And it was, it was a hard moment, you know,
cause it wasn't, I mean, it wasn't devastating loss,
but it was a split decision loss. I'd never thought it would happen like that.
And especially not to that motherfucker. I was like, dude, I talk so much shit.
I tried to build that fight up. Oh it was so it was like,
I can't believe I did all this work and then came up short because I just fucked
. I just shot myself in the foot, whatever.
And the next day we went to the pool because it was early and she likes to sleep
in. She, when she gets the opportunity to work, she's on vacation.
She could sleep. She sleeps at fucking me. I'm like, I'm up eight, nine o'clock.
I'm, I'm, I'm out. I'm having a drink and by the pool,
feet up and I'm under my umbrella cause I try not to Tan.
I already got enough of that. And um, she comes up where you at?
And I,
I think I go back to the room and then he turns into another fucking fight.
And at that point, that's when I kind of like, you know what?
I don't give a fuck. I'm talking anybody, any girl
I see, I think there's, hi, I'm going to talk to them. And if I get called,
I get called. I don't really give a shit anymore and I could get caught. And uh,
it w we, it was a rocky, very rocky time and I was just, like I said,
I was just drinking nonstop and I was just,
I was just kind of being a fuck up man. I didn't mind.
I never did like hardcore drugs, anything. I, you know, I was smoke,
but this is hard psychologically to handle like a big loss like that.
Is that what it is? He just throws you off. You know what,
you know, I've lost a lot of my life. You know,
I would think that I battled back from a lot of adversity just dealing with the
stuff when my dad and my parents, um, them going through mold,
my dad going through a few divorces and uh, the, the,
the domestic abuse and you know,
being the first one to go to college and finish college becoming a two time all
American,
like I have a lot of things to be proud of and a lot of things that set me back.
But I was able to overcome those obstacles and then to have that happen.
And you know,
I thought this was my call and I thought it's gonna be the Floyd Mayweather of f
a MMA man. Well you know,
sometimes when you come from a background where you've had a lot of losses and a
lot of bad things have happened, but then all of a sudden,
great things are happening. You're moving forward and you got progress.
Setbacks are sometimes even more devastating cause you started thinking about
going back to the way things used to be or the way maybe your parents lived or
the way other people you know lived.
And when you see that life and you're like fuck this,
I can't believe I lost because you had anticipated that you were just going to
keep moving forward. So when it does happen,
sometimes it's more devastating than someone who doesn't have high aspirations
and isn't on a roll. You know, sometimes when you're on a roll,
like a real roll and you lose, it's like the worst thing that can happen. Yeah.
Cause you think fuck, I thought everything had changed.
I thought I had re just reshaped my future. Yeah.
Now you're 100% right. And I thought,
I thought I was on the cusp of really changing my family's life.
This was before things really got crazy with like the, the divorce and my,
my dad and my dad can't came out of jail 2014 and October.
And from there it just been a shit storm. Like damn,
calling the cops on each other and getting orders, orders of protection.
I had my brothers even like writing like you know what Jamal,
the guy on gcs smell.
So smell lay or the guy who made up that fake thing like he got,
he got a smaller yeah with the,
with the hanging thing and say like people jumped him and a whatever.
So that guy, they would put like his like draw him on my,
on my door like on a picture and posted on my door whenever I would leave for
fights or leaf, their training,
I'll come home and me and my brothers were bumping heads and um,
it was like my dad and like his side of my,
not my mom's kids like the other side, like the other half,
it was like them against like me cause I was such a,
it was like they will fuck with me in the house and it was like, dude,
I don't understand how you guys see one person, like really,
really trying to do something and push for like to be successful with something
and you guys just want tear it down. I
mean, our relationship is so much better now. So let me make sure I say that.
But back then it was so toxic, man. And I was dealing with that at a point.
Eventually I had just get the fuck out of the house,
but my girlfriend was there. She was there for, from all that chaos and shit.
So when she was like being the negative Nancy and I felt like, Yo,
this is just so,
so much burden going on in my life and now you're sh you're adding to it by
stressing me the fuck out. And I was like, dude, I just,
I just rather just be alone, you know, and uh,
just be a fucking bachelor with a bachelor's. And I'm like,
this is the way life was supposed to play out. It's like,
I guess this is what happened. Like I thought she,
she like showed her true colors,
but I knew deep down she just cared about me and she just wanted me to do the
right thing and she didn't know how to handle a boyfriend being in the
spotlight. You know, I'm,
I'm pretty sure you've probably had your fair share of like battles coming up.
Like it's challenging. And for the, for the male,
the person I even a male guy or female, whoever's in the spotlight,
being able to handle that and do the right thing.
And in certain situations it can be very, very tough sometimes. You know,
and I think a person in your position to where you're so close
shot at the title,
there's so many things that could go wrong that could fuck you up or go right
and could elevate you.
And it's a delicate balancing act with personal life economics,
your health training trainers, training partners,
like everything has to kind of be in place.
If you're eventually gonna make that next step and, and gain the title,
it's like, yeah,
there's that weird and there's a lot of stress involved with something like
that.
Well you are managing all these things and so any problem that you might have in
your relationship goes sour that fucks everything up because then the whole
system is all wacky. If the system is smooth like you,
you and your girl get along good. You and your training partners get along good.
Everything's good. We're all positive and moving in the right direction.
Do you have less ripples in the water? We're good. We're good. We're good.
And then that good or bad can have a significant impact on your future right
now?
Yeah. No, I, I, I agree 100%. It's a, it's, it's,
it's just been a really crazy roller coaster, like, uh,
eight and like even going on in that range. I, that's when I had the injury.
I remember trying to spot, I was like, you know what? I looked at my life.
I was like, dude, I've just been partying since my loss. It was,
was it May 29th or 27th Memorial Day weekend on a Sunday.
And ever since then I,
I think I probably drank like almost every single fucking day for how many
months? Um,
all the way to July when I had had this surgery and no one really knows me and I
was like, I was in a bad way, like mentally.
And to be able to pull myself back together was, it was tough man.
And uh, I'm just happy I was able to do it.
But then like I remember I came back, I was like, you know what,
let's get out of this guy shit together. I think,
I think it was maybe owl or somebody else had a fight coming up.
And that was like kind of like the catalyst for me to have the new found
motivation to get back.
And then I come back and I tried to spar and I popped my,
I popped my bicep tenant cause I'm just, I'm just on this binging drink,
I'm just going nuts. Your body is probably,
we dehydrated and I go and I throw a long check hook, which I always do.
I don't know if you've seen it in the fights.
When I stepped back and I always counted with the opposite hand and I hit guys
on my own, that transition going backwards and that's all I did. Connected,
flush, pop. And then from there it was a, another setback. And I was like,
how many wants to take for that to Rehab? Three I didn't,
I didn't feel comfortable taking a fight until probably like the third month.
And then I was like, all right, let's,
I didn't fight for the rest of the 2016 so I didn't fight again until I fought a
sunset in January.
It's what do you do during that time when you have like a giant gap like that we
not making any money. I went back to teaching for a little bit.
I was coaching the wrestling team and I was coaching at the high school program
at a Baldwin High School doing that and it was cool, but you know,
you're not making any real money so to speak because it's not like a real full
time job. Um,
so I had figured I had to figure things out real quick and that's why I always
thanked myself for not being like when these guys who mixed their money and just
go on these spending sprees and just blow their money.
Like people see me like traveling up there. We fight, which I do enjoy,
but I'm smart about it. I always try to do it on like the UFC is diamond.
I try to be, be a guest fied for every single event. I enjoy these things.
It's not a,
it's not a burden for me to go out and sign pictures to get a free flight to go
to Liverpool and just extend my trip and have everything paid for. I see that.
Just let you do that. If you want to go, well you ask and if they have,
if they have room to pay for it. And I went to Poland doing that. Oh that's bad.
Yeah. So I take advantage of these things, you know. How long do you go for?
It depends. I was in a London for seven days, but I went, I ex,
that whole trip was two weeks. So I started in London cause I had,
my grandma still lives out there and some of my cousins and uncles.
So I went out there and visited them, hung out, we got shit face. And then, uh,
we went to Liverpool,
watched the fight when the boy versus out Darren till crazy, crazy fight.
And then, um, the last three days I saw Kevin.
I actually have a video on my phone.
I don't know if it might not be on my phone, might be on my laptop,
but I have a video of him and I grappling drunk in the lobby of the hotel in
Liverpool after the fights. And I told him I was coming out to a,
I told him I was coming out to Ireland and that was like my introduction to him
and I, we became like pretty cool ever since.
And then I went out to Ireland to go train and got to work with Brad Catona uh,
James Gallaher her for a little bit and get some work in and tour the island a
little bit. So that was fun. But then I went to Poland,
so I've done a lot of these trips and even courting a OCHA Sasaki when he fought
in Singapore,
I extended my trip and I went to Bali right after cause I have some long island
friends and I stayed out there for a week. That's an amazing place.
That's the place I want to go to flight is Bali luck.
Cause I almost went there last summer. We decided to go to Thailand instead.
But have you served before? No. It's a, it's, it's a great place for surfing.
You're not scared of sharks? Not Shark yesterday.
No. Don't do this through Jamie. 25 to 30
feet long. 5,000 pounds. Wow. What? Yeah.
[inaudible] at this like jaws is real shit. This, I chose this route.
The biggest shark ever, right Scott to be. What did, when did this get solved?
Someone said it to me yesterday as I just remember watching it on my phone and
you just like set it and popped right in my head. That's done baby shark ever.
It's like the shack of human beings for the sharpish put in exaggerating those
numbers, but that's what it says here. Here's the tweet.
What is this from Twitter? Twitter. Martha's vineyard shows does exist.
Watch how big this fucking thing is. Okay, here it go.
There's the tail right here. Martha's vineyard. Isn't that split? It was, yeah.
Oh my God. Dude. It's so big. Oh my God. Wow.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
That is so big. Do not just fuck with people. It's hard.
Perspective wise, those numbers could be slightly exaggerated.
Listen that that 25 to 30 feet, 5,000 pounds. How do you know who's saying this?
Who's posting this? What is this group? Gregory Long. What does he do?
I don't know. I'll look up. And what do you do, Gregory?
What is his actual credentials at that? He doesn't seem like to be a shark guy,
but it's his Wednesday wisdom. How's that wisdom? All right Greg,
what are you talking about? Great Guy. Great. You drop it.
Find out that Greg's drunk at work.
That might've just been 15 feet. It might be a regular grade. Either way.
Fucking giant might not have been really one in Hawaii that they monitor.
Right?
And they have a chip and it's called like deep blue or big blue or something
like that. Something like that. Yeah. And that's the biggest one they know of.
Correct. But I thought that was significantly smaller. Like 20 feet us.
A bunch of websites ran the story. Oh, but Twitter user,
Gregory Long posted a video. But there's no perspective though. It's, it's,
there's not a boat that you can look at. We can say, oh, this is a 15 foot boat.
Look at it. It's 10 feet longer than the boat. Yeah. Come on Greg.
Stop being drunk at work.
Either way. Fuck sharks.
Yeah, but you, I think you would enjoy it cause it's, sure. I love it.
There's training there too. Uh, my Guy Anthony Leoni, Donny, Donny,
Carla Kloss and his brother Andrew Leoni, different long island,
but they just been moving,
hopping around to different places and they set up a gym and bar.
They started in Thailand,
I guess they had like a little fallen out and he told me like they tried to
like,
they threaten to kill him or like threatened to tell them like you can't leave
like in a way where it was like threatening like you,
you're not leaving this place. But they left,
they got out of there and I guess in Bali they have like a law where outside is
foreigners can't buy property unless there's like an Indonesian like uh,
leasing it to you or like joint partners or something like that. Huh.
Something interesting like that,
which I thought was pretty cool because they have some,
you can live in a very nice too bedroom,
very nice place with a pool, with a garage,
get a scooter for like $2,000 for the year,
which is like insane and for a year for like, yes for you.
I asked the guy, Donnie, how much he paid. I don't want to misquote him,
but I want to say he had to pay 2,500 for the year or for two years,
something like that. While I was like, Yo Bro, I could come here right now.
Live like a fucking cake as black parents, everybody, I'll see you later.
Well I think it's really attractive to these young guys that go to Thailand and
do their camps out there. Well not just young guys. This isn't Valentine.
Shevchenko didn't she do a lot of our training down in Thailand to Tyga Moitai
was it thing she did? It was either that or who kept top team.
I forget which one, but I'm in an Aka mom, Mike Swick,
he's got Aka Thailand now too.
There's so many places down there where guys go and train and you see like a
great result too.
Like Kahlil Rountree he went down there and came back a fucking assassin.
That was a fun episode you guys had when he was talking about his training.
Yeah, it was great. Yeah, but these are all these destinations.
Gyms are popping up but that's what they have over there in Bali they called
Bali MMA but it's been, they got the food like right on site so you don't,
you don't need anything. You go there. There's the showers,
there's the food shop and so healthy stuff too, which is pretty sick.
What's going on Jamie. Yet people think that most likely was a basking shark,
which is an average size of 11,000 pounds.
Why do you think it's a basking shark? Because it's because of the size of it.
Yeah, but it didn't look a fucking shark. I was going to argue that like I know
they don't know shit cause I want it to be a great white,
but there were a bunch of things.
There were a lot of great white sightings in that area. Over that weekend,
so fuck up. Who knows? Yeah. Yeah, man. Sharks. Fuck sharks.
So basking sharks get that big. They get dry. They had that giant mouth.
They're not dangerous. They got a weird face. The sucking
Krill and stuff like, Whoa, look at the inside.
All bones. No.
Yeah, it looks like a tube that kind of looks like the same,
but could be only that other one had that wide Alex now. No, it didn't.
But that might be a white ass mouth while it's open. Right?
Maybe if the mouth is closed. Hey Greg, do you know what the fuck you're saying?
Let me see. Oh, that looks different than me, man. Time and Gills would be on.
Let's take a look yet. God Damn Great. Why? Man, I don't know.
Let's call these apps. That's a great white shark.
That might really be a 25 foot shark. Dude that looked really showed that.
Again, that was always fucking gigantic.
Sorry for calling you drunk. Greg. Look at that. Whoa. Well,
imagine being in a Kayak and you gotta quit pot,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Ah, ah, ah,
that's so big. I'm surprised those things. They don't fuck with people man.
Like you see a ship,
you just don't just start charging into it and like I'm gonna fucking knock this
thing over and get a little snack. A little snacky Pooh. I don't know.
I saw the episode like the little snippet that Dana White
in a Matt, Sarah, Newtown has put out. I was like get the fuck outta here.
Go into the water with sharks. I could never,
why couldn't go surfing but never leave dean did it like he seems wise.
It seems wise. It is. Plaque was supposed to be smarter than this dean.
It's Sarah Jones in there too. Everybody jumped in there.
Did you talk to Matt about it? No, I just saw the snippets.
I've been out here so find,
and it looks like there was like blood in the water too.
Like they threw pieces of meat in the water jumping in. She used to say like,
look at this. Fuck it. Yeah.
See there's pieces of meat in the water and they were all, my God,
they were counting like one, two,
three fuck everything about that walk. Everything about that can never,
I could never do that shit just as a dumb way to dime.
Dana White's looking for a fight. How did Matt Serra die? Oh,
his fucking youtube show fucked up. Okay.
The whites looking for a fight. Yeah. Why would they do that?
They're yelling and screaming at Jane is laughing. Right? Isn't it funny?
Dan White's worth like a half a billion dollars and he's still gets his kicks
doing silly shit like this. Yeah.
I mean that shows a fun show because Dana's not doing that for money.
Not by any stretch of the imagination. He's doing that to have a good time.
Yeah. I mean, I love that. I love that aspect of what he does.
Like Dana is a fucking legitimate wild man. Yeah.
I really did choose to hang out with him. I love him. Maybe if I went to bed,
like I get hang out privileges as I'll do the same man,
next time I'm hanging out with y'all with him. I'll invite you if you love Dana.
He's crazy. He's, he mean he's the perfect dude. I always say this when I,
you know, I do the, um,
the announcing at the Wayans when Dana comes on stage. I always say without him,
none of this would be possible cause it wouldn't, yeah, he wouldn't,
he needed a wild man to take control of this fucking crazy sport.
Cause most people would want to tone it down or change things about it or, yeah.
I mean he's, and the only reason I did commentary Evers,
cause he asked me to do it. I never wanted to do commentary.
That wasn't my idea. That's Dana White's idea.
I'll tell you fucking what fucking killed it though. Well,
I got lucky that I got a chance in the early days when no one was watching to
learn to do it and get better at it cause I wasn't that good in the beginning.
It's still like, it takes a while to figure out how to do it.
But you are doing fear factor.
Before that I was doing fear factor and when I was doing fear factor, I,
that's when [inaudible] had just purchased the UFC.
So I came to watch a,
when Tito Ortiz five Vladimir [inaudible] Shanko and a I w I went to,
um, some of the earlier fights, like when Matt Hughes fought soccer,
I was in the audience and everything like that.
And Dana and I used to have conversations about fights and I would say, hey,
you know, you should check out these guys and this guy in Japan,
you'd check out this Russian dude. And,
and we were just talking about fights and I was just,
I would always be asking them questions and what do you guys got coming up next?
And I thought it was exciting because the sport was trying to take off and they
were risking all this money.
Like I was there hanging out with them as a friend when the, uh,
pay-per-view cut short, cause they had a window of time for pay-per-view,
Tito Ortiz, flop Vat. Vladimir met Yushchenko right after September 11th.
So it was this big patriotic thing and everybody felt terrible.
Like this is right after nine 11 and Tito comes out with the American flag and
it was this big deal. And then the paper view,
the time stopped in the middle of the fight and they just,
the screen went black and everybody wanted their money back so they lost a shit
ton of money and I was hanging out with them as you know,
just a friend when all this was happening. And then somewhere around a,
I think it was UFC 37 and a half,
Dana talked me into doing commentary because they were doing,
it was in promotion with Fox sports and the best damn sports show.
I remember that show. Best Damn sports show period. Yep.
They were helping promote it and so all that stuff happened together and then
they talked me into,
Dana talked me into doing commentary and I did it ever since.
So w w when did you actually meet him?
Like met him in like 2000, right when they bought it,
like 2001. What happened was they bought the UFC,
then they started putting on these events in Vegas and you know,
Eddie Bravo and I,
we had always said what this sport needs is some crazy billionaire who loves the
sport, who just dumps a bunch of money in it to make it, to make it big.
Because when I first started doing commentary was in 97.
It was when it was presumed. It was a,
the old days when Bob Meyrowitz owned it and Bob hired me and Campbell McLaren
and I was just doing the post-fight interviews. I'd interview guys, you know,
after the fight was over. And then, um, I quit.
I did it for like maybe two years, but it was just too much work.
It was actually costing me money. It wasn't,
there's not a lot of money in interviewing fighters. You know,
there wasn't money in the sport back then and I just did it cause I loved it.
But it got to a point where like if I took a weekend off to do that versus do
comedy, it would cost me like a few thousand dollars.
And I was like I can't do this anymore. And so I quit.
And then when I got fear factor, I wound up uh,
go into one of their Vegas events cause the UFC just bought this and they were
giving out free tickets to celebrities. And so that's how Dana and I met. Yeah.
And then we just started talking about fights and he talked me into doing it.
That's crazy. That's crazy. I never,
never in my wildest dreams thought I would ever be a sports commentator. No,
no desire to do it whatsoever. And I remember early on someone,
I remember who it was, was telling Dana like, hey,
he's got to stop talking about weed. And Dan,
his exact words were,
I don't give a fuck why he talks about as long as he talks about the fights.
I mean,
no one else would say that like as a CEO or a president of a giant billion
dollar organization, I would say that. Yeah, no one say that.
It takes a wild man. He's different, man. He'd given up on the TV. Right? I
have it on my computer on. It's about to start here. Fucking, Hey,
you've got it on here. That's because it's [inaudible]. There we go.
He beat up his cousin. Oh, Ray Cooper's about the fight. John Howard,
he beat his cousin up. He beat his cousin. He fought his cousin. His last one.
Ray Cooper. Oh my God. Shields. He fucked up. Jake scheels twice in a row.
That's one of the weird things about that organization.
Are you doing this through your computer? Is that,
are you doing it because I have a boy. He fought. He fought his cousin.
Call those dudes. Oh, there it goes. Oh, there it goes. Damn. Oh No,
it's cause it's still going through my computer.
So no one really talked about that. Why is that thing in the middle of it?
I'm trying to switch the inputs to o box on. He's uh, you know, their,
their thing is weird the way they do it is weird the way the PFL does it yet.
Like you have to fight
to get into the, to get into the playoffs.
This should be wild as fuck. Cause John Howard can crack.
He hits like a fucking, he cracks, they both crack.
And John has fought a lot of high level dudes that they're on the bottom line.
That guy, he got his arm ripped off in a crash over the weekend.
Well it felt player. Oh, I heard about that. What happens?
Fucked up.
Just got started in the crash and said so I think it was his contract. Right.
What the fuck.
Unless they can rebuild them like Steve Austin or the billion dollar man as a
defensive tackle. Offensive guys. Now they can't, you can't have one arm.
But the one guy playing with no, like two fingers off in a,
a fireworks accident a couple of years ago. What you wanna hear about that?
He was like j p Ganache to contract. Like he's still NFL PA.
He's done now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's done. No. Now like as of this season,
I think God damn my boxing coach in Boston has finger bitten off in a street
fight and he replaced it with is a second toe,
not the big toe but the second one and they had it curled permanently so he
could always throw right hooks that rough camp ref can look at them. I was like,
what the fuck is these stats? They're going to show up on the screen too,
like striking speed and how much they move around the ring.
Ray Cooper moving in quick. Boom. Big Kick taken down.
Ray Cooper is also state champion wrestler from Hawaii. Yeah,
I heard that his ass off. I was just found it weird that he fought his cousin.
I guess they had like a, he, they,
he was mad that his cousin is septic to be in the tournament knowing that he was
in a tournament first. Well probably not the best idea. Yeah,
that didn't hit so God damn hard. He hits hard. But you fucked your cousin. No,
well I fought my cousin when I was seven.
We got in a fight King Kong versus Godzilla. I was a,
I was a King Kong man. My cousins, my brothers used to beat my fucking ass.
We used to beat each other's ass as though they would jump me.
They would jump me. Really? Yeah. We jumped each other though.
We how many tough guys came from a family where their brothers beat their ass?
Probably a lot. A lot. The number's got to be
through the roof. I think about it, right? Like tough guys with brothers.
First of all, Matt Hughes and his brother Mark. Whoa. Beautiful takedown. Oh,
he hit him with a nice left hook there.
That was a clean left hook in the transition. Um, uh,
the Miller's Dan Miller and Jim Miller. Uh,
the other Miller's Cole Miller and Micah Miller.
How many fucking animals have brothers and they fight with their brother?
Yeah. Yeah. It's like a lot. Oh Shit. I don't know. Mary Cooper. Landon. Yeah.
Oh Wow. God. How are would a big left hook?
Oh my goodness, y'all. That was, oh, that was great. Oh,
he's out. He's out. John Howard.
Whoa. Sean Howard. Holy Y'all.
Shit. We were just saying that man.
John Howard can fuck can crack. Damn.
[inaudible] eh, um, Whoa Lee shit.
And he's got a huge one. That's a nice knot. That's let's,
let's end this podcast on a positive note. Shout out to John Howard.
Congratulations. So Bostonian and a shout out to funk master.
Uh, tell people how they can get you on Instagram and Twitter and all that jazz.
Uh, they can find me on, uh,
Instagram Funkmaster underscore UFC and on the tweeter, the tweet, a tweet, uh,
funk mass underscore UFC and um, oh yeah, you could go to my website.
[inaudible] where I got my podcast or took is on iTunes and what's it called?
The n the weekly scratched. Cause this fights every weekend.
There is pretty niche pretty much now. Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Well,
thank you brother. I appreciate you, man. Thank you man.
Coming in to watch his fights. I really enjoyed it. Yeah.
We're going to watch the fights now. Nobody see you, John Howard.
Okay.
[inaudible]
mm.